What's better than a well-marbled ribby sizzling on the barbecue? A well-marbled ribby sizzling on the barbecue that was carefully selected by an Instacart shopper and delivered to your door. A well-marbled ribby you ordered without even leaving the kitty pool. Whatever groceries your summer calls for, Instacart has you covered. Download the Instacart app and enjoy $0 delivery fees on your first three orders. Service fees, exclusions, and terms apply. Instacart, groceries that over-deliver. We have some fun merch news.
有什么比在烧烤架上滋滋作响、纹理完美的肋眼牛排更好的呢？那就是由Instacart购物者精心挑选并送到您家门口的、在烧烤架上滋滋作响、纹理完美的肋眼牛排。甚至不用离开儿童戏水池就能订购到纹理完美的肋眼牛排。无论您的夏天需要什么杂货，Instacart都能满足您。下载Instacart应用程序，前三单即可享受0美元配送费。服务费、除外条款和适用条款。Instacart，超值配送的杂货服务。我们有一些有趣的周边新闻。
Yes. We are back with a limited time, a pop-up merch store. Yes, and we have brand new Office Ladies merch for you. It is available September 3rd through September 17th. We've got some classic designs that we know you love, plus an all-new Scranton Hot collection. We also have a super cute Finer Things Club tote and a water bottle that says Office Ladies, sassy since 2019. So if you've been waiting for
是的。我们带着限时快闪周边商店回来了。没错，我们为您准备了全新的《办公室》女士周边商品。将于9月3日至9月17日期间发售。我们有一些您喜爱的经典设计，还有全新的“斯克兰顿辣味”系列。我们还有一个超级可爱的“精致事物俱乐部”手提袋和一个水瓶，上面写着“办公室女士，自2019年以来就很时髦”。所以，如果您一直在等待
new Office Ladies merch for yourself, your best friend, your sister, your mom, your hubby, now's your chance. Head to shopofficeladies.com and get your order in today. Hello and welcome to your second drink of the negotiation. This is a really special episode because David Denman joined us to talk about his time on the office. Love him. And this episode is super packed. We have a Jim Roy, a Roy Pam breakup, and then a Dwight Angela a makeout session caught by the documentary camera crew and Jim. And guys, it's a super-sized episode. Well, Ange, I remember you saying that there are no deleted scenes on the DVDs for this episode because it was supersized. Did any extra footage make it into the superfan episode?
为您自己、最好的朋友、姐妹、妈妈或丈夫购买全新的《办公室》女士周边，现在就是机会。前往shopofficeladies.com，今天就下单吧。您好，欢迎来到您的第二杯谈判饮品。这是一集非常特别的节目，因为大卫·丹曼加入了我们，谈论他在《办公室》的时光。爱死他了。这一集内容非常丰富。我们有吉姆和罗伊的冲突，罗伊和帕姆的分手，还有被纪录片摄制组和吉姆撞见的德怀特和安吉拉的亲热戏。伙计们，这是一集超长版。嗯，安吉，我记得你说过这一集DVD里没有删减片段，因为它是超长版。有什么额外的镜头被放进超级粉丝版了吗？
I was curious, too. So here's the deal. The running time of the original episode was 30 minutes, and the superfan is 32 minutes and 34 seconds. So they did not add a lot. I was curious. What is this extra two minutes. Well, the first thing added I found was to Pam's talking head where she says she doesn't want to comment on the Jim Roy fight. The original was this. Pam says, I don't really want to talk about it. I don't mean to be rude, but I just, I don't want to comment on what happened. It sucked and it stopped there. But here is the extended cut. I really don't want to talk about it. I don't mean to be rude, but I just don't want to comment on what happened. It sucked. probably the only time I'll ever utter the words.
我也很好奇。情况是这样的。原版的时长是30分钟，而超级粉丝版是32分34秒。所以他们并没有增加太多。我很好奇，这多出来的两分钟是什么。嗯，我发现增加的第一部分是帕姆的采访镜头，她说她不想评论吉姆和罗伊的打架事件。原版是这样的。帕姆说，我真的不想谈论它。我不是想粗鲁，但我只是，我不想评论发生了什么。这太糟糕了，然后就结束了。但这是加长版。我真的不想谈论它。我不是想粗鲁，但我只是不想评论发生了什么。这太糟糕了。这可能是我唯一一次说出这些话。
But luckily, Dwight came along. That's fun. Isn't that cute? Yes. And I found one more. It's in the car with Toby, Michael, and Daryl. So remember how Daryl says, I haven't been to New York in a long time.
但幸运的是，德怀特出现了。那很有趣。不可爱吗？是的。我还发现了一个。是在托比、迈克尔和达里尔的车里。还记得达里尔是怎么说的吗，我很久没去纽约了。
Maybe I'll stay overnight. I've got a cousin that lives down there. And then Toby says, how would we get home? And Daryl says, oh, you could stay too. He's got a big place. And then Michael chimes in, maybe I'll stay. And then Daryl is like, his place isn't that big. Yes.
也许我会过夜。我有个表亲住在那儿。然后托比说，我们怎么回家？达里尔说，哦，你也可以留下。他住的地方很大。然后迈克尔插嘴说，也许我会留下。然后达里尔说，他住的地方没那么大。是的。
So he totally doesn't want Michael. But he's fine if Toby tags along. Well, there was more after that. It wasn't in deleted scenes, but I checked the shooting draft. It's in there. And it all made it into the superfan version. Let's hear it. I've been in New York in a long time.
所以他完全不想让迈克尔留下。但他不介意托比跟着。嗯，那之后还有更多内容。它不在删减片段里，但我查了拍摄剧本。里面有。而且都放进了超级粉丝版里。我们来听听。我很久没去纽约了。
Big apple. I'll stay all night. Got a cousin live down here. And when we get home? Oh, you can stay too. He's got a big place. They out there. It's not that big.
大苹果城。我会待一整晚。有个表亲住在这儿。那我们怎么回家？哦，你也可以留下。他住的地方很大。他们在那儿。没那么大。
The buses, though, get you home quick. Hold on. Tell me, maybe the men's in town. We catch a game in that stuff. Seriously? Tell me not into baseball. I like baseball. Or you could head down in Times Square, find yourself a hooker.
不过，巴士能让你很快回家。等等。告诉我，也许男人们在城里。我们去看场比赛之类的。说真的？告诉我你对棒球不感兴趣。我喜欢棒球。或者你可以去时代广场，找个妓女。
Forget about your divorce for a minute. Michael, I am so sick of those jokes. Sorry, I'm sorry, so he'll help me. Psychopath. Yeah, and then at the end, Michael leans forward and goes, psychopath. Toby bites back. Yeah. Some Toby's ass.
暂时忘掉你的离婚吧。迈克尔，我真是受够了那些笑话。抱歉，我很抱歉，所以他会帮我。精神病。是的，然后在最后，迈克尔向前倾身说，精神病。托比反击。是的。托比的屁股。
I wanted to share a fan catch by Sandikin T, who pointed out an office crossover that we missed. She said in Dwight's final talking head when he's talking about who the real he's, Heroes are. And then he mentions Hero from the TV show Heroes. Right. We did not mention that Nicholas DeGosto, who plays Hunter and who we meet in this episode, is also in Heroes. He was in nine episodes of Heroes. And of course, our other office heroes crossovers are Jack Coleman and Sent Hill Rama Murthy. Hunter was in nine episodes? Yeah, of Heroes, the TV show. That's a great catch. Thank you, Sandikin. Heroes is now. like really making a run for Monk in terms of office crossovers.
我想分享一个粉丝Sandikin T的发现，她指出了一个我们错过的《办公室》联动。她说在德怀特的最后一段采访中，当他谈到谁是真正的英雄时。然后他提到了电视剧《英雄》里的英雄。没错。我们没有提到在这一集中出现的扮演亨特的尼古拉斯·德戈斯托也出演了《英雄》。他出演了九集《英雄》。当然，我们其他的《办公室》与《英雄》联动演员还有杰克·科尔曼和森德希·拉玛莫西。亨特出演了九集？是的，电视剧《英雄》。这是一个很棒的发现。谢谢你，Sandikin。现在《英雄》在《办公室》联动方面真的快要赶上《神探阿蒙》了。
It is. But you know what? These crossovers don't surprise me because Heroes was a big hit show on NBC at the same time that the office was on. Right. And what happens is like if you do a guest appearance on one network show, they now kind of know about you. Right.
确实。但你知道吗？这些联动并不让我惊讶，因为《英雄》和《办公室》在NBC播出时都是大热剧。没错。发生的情况是，如果你在一家电视网的节目中客串，他们现在就会了解你。没错。
So you're more top of mind if they've got a role that might fit you on one of their other shows. Exactly. So that makes sense to me why so many folks were on both shows. Yeah. Well, lastly, there is a scene we briefly discuss, but you guys, it is one of my favorite Jan phone conversations with Michael. Every time I rewatch this episode, it makes me laugh. Every single time, I think we should hear it. He has been wanting to raise for a couple of months, and he's just using this Roy thing as leverage.
所以如果他们有适合你的角色，你会更容易出现在他们的脑海里。没错。所以这对我来说很有道理，为什么这么多人同时出演了两部剧。是的。嗯，最后，有一个我们简短讨论过的场景，但伙计们，这是我最喜欢的简和迈克尔的电话交谈之一。每次我重看这一集，它都让我发笑。每一次，我想我们应该听听。他已经想加薪好几个月了，他只是利用罗伊这件事作为筹码。
Are you going to take care of this? Yeppers. What did I tell you about yeppers? I don't remember. I told you not to say it. Do you remember that? Yeesh. Every time.
你会处理这件事吗？是的。我跟你说过多少次关于“是的”这个词？我不记得了。我告诉过你不要说它。你记得吗？哎呀。每一次。
What did I tell you about yeppers? And then he says, yeesh. I'm sure that bothers her just as much. And the whole time Toby is sitting there, just listening to the whole conversation on speakerphone in the conference room. But how many times has he said yeppers that she bites so hard like that? Yeah. Oh, my gosh. I love it.
我跟你说过多少次关于“是的”这个词？然后他说，哎呀。我相信那让她同样感到困扰。而且整个过程中托比都坐在那里，只是在会议室里通过免提听着整个对话。但他说了多少次“是的”，让她反应这么大？是的。哦，天哪。我喜欢它。
Okay. Lastly, we both have some fun personal news. Y'all, I finally got the physical copy of Josh and I's cookbook. You can make this. We are so excited. We finally got to hold it. We got to flip through it. This is two years of hard work.
好的。最后，我们俩都有一些有趣的个人消息。大家，我终于拿到了我和乔什的食谱实体书。你可以做这个。我们太兴奋了。我们终于拿到了它。我们翻阅了它。这是两年的心血。
Our kids got to look at it. We're so excited. I am so happy for you guys. Thank you. I need everyone to know how amazing it is to eat at your house. And now with this cookbook, everybody can eat all the stuff that you've been serving me for years. I mean, forever. Thanks, lady. My kids get very excited when they are invited to your house. They literally say,
我们的孩子看到了它。我们太兴奋了。我真为你们感到高兴。谢谢。我需要让每个人都知道在你家吃饭是多么棒。现在有了这本食谱，每个人都可以吃到你多年来一直招待我的那些东西。我是说，永远。谢谢，女士。我的孩子们被邀请到你家时非常兴奋。他们真的说，
Josh makes such good food. You know, our kids' friends always want to eat at our house. I don't doubt it. I love it. Well, thank you for saying that. That means a lot. And I can't wait for you guys to have it. We'll put links in stories. And lady, you, you have it. You, have a huge night tonight. We have to talk about it. I know. I kind of got to go. My play, Ashland Avenue, opens tonight at the Goodman Theater in Chicago. Opening night is by invitation only, but you can get tickets to all our other shows at Goodmantheter.org. But yeah, I got to go. I got to go start my vocal warmups. Lady, you're going to do great, as they say in the theater, break a leg. Thank you. I love you. And now here's our breakdown of the negotiation full of
乔什做的饭真好吃。你知道，我们孩子的朋友总是想在我们家吃饭。我不怀疑。我喜欢它。嗯，谢谢你这么说。这意义重大。我迫不及待想让你们拥有它。我们会把链接放在故事里。还有女士，你，你拥有它。你，今晚有个重要的夜晚。我们得谈谈。我知道。我得走了。我的剧《阿什兰大道》今晚在芝加哥的古德曼剧院首演。首演之夜仅限受邀者参加，但你可以在Goodmantheater.org购买我们其他演出的门票。但是的，我得走了。我得去开始我的发声练习了。女士，你会表现得很棒的，正如他们在剧院里说的，祝你好运。谢谢。我爱你。现在这是我们对《谈判》的解析，充满了
fun stuff and one of my favorite Jenna deep dives, pockets. Oh, boy. I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week, we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're the office ladies. Hello, Angela. Hey, lady. It's very good to see your face today.
有趣的东西和我最喜欢的珍娜深度挖掘之一，口袋。哦，天哪。我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金赛。我们一起出演了《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为您制作终极《办公室》重温播客。每周，我们将解析一集《办公室》，并提供只有两个亲历者才能告诉您的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室》女士。你好，安吉拉。嘿，女士。今天见到你的脸真好。
Same. I feel the same way. Oh, I said lady right out of the gate. Jenna, some people love the lady and some people don't love the lady. I want to get a t-shirt that just says lady. Lady. All right. What are we talking about today?
一样。我也一样。哦，我一开口就说了女士。珍娜，有些人喜欢女士，有些人不喜欢女士。我想买一件只写着女士的T恤。女士。好了。我们今天在谈论什么？
Today we are talking about season three, episode 18, the negotiation. It was written by Mike Scher and directed by Jeff Blitz. Those are two powerhouses of comedy. Yes, this is a good team. Here is a summary. Angered by Pam's confession that she and Jim shared a kiss, Roy tries to attack Jim in the office. I mean, right out of the gate.
今天我们谈论的是第三季第18集，《谈判》。它由迈克·舒尔编写，杰夫·布里茨执导。那是两位喜剧界的重量级人物。是的，这是一个很好的团队。这是一个摘要。因为帕姆承认她和吉姆接吻了，罗伊试图在办公室攻击吉姆。我是说，一上来就是这样。
That's the first scene, everybody. Yeah. Jim is spared by Dwight's quick thinking, aka Pepper Spray. Roy is fired and Daryl tries to leverage it into a raise. But upon hearing how little Michael makes, at his job, Daryl, Toby, and Michael drive to corporate so Michael can ask for his own raise. Roy takes Pam out for coffee to apologize and they break it off for good. This is it.
那是第一个场景，各位。是的。吉姆因为德怀特的快速反应，也就是胡椒喷雾，而幸免于难。罗伊被解雇了，达里尔试图利用这一点来要求加薪。但在听说迈克尔在工作中的薪水有多低后，达里尔、托比和迈克尔开车去公司，这样迈克尔就可以要求加薪。罗伊带帕姆出去喝咖啡道歉，他们彻底分手了。就是这样。
No more Pam and Roy guys. And then at the end of the show, Jim catches Dwight and Angela kissing. in the office. Mm-hmm. It's a lot. It's a lot. Fast fact number one.
伙计们，帕姆和罗伊再也没有了。然后在节目最后，吉姆撞见德怀特和安吉拉在办公室接吻。嗯哼。内容很多。内容很多。速记事实第一条。
This episode was a supersized episode of the office. And as a result, Angela, I think, am I right? There are no deleted scenes for this episode. There are none on the DVDs.
这一集是《办公室》的超长版。结果，安吉拉，我想，我说的对吗？这一集没有删减片段。DVD里一个都没有。
Now, I don't know if there's some secret NBC archive somewhere, but there aren't any that we know of. I think we used it all. It's all in there, guys. Now, here's a little bit of a fact.
现在，我不知道某个地方是否有秘密的NBC档案，但据我们所知没有。我想我们都用上了。都在里面了，伙计们。现在，这是一个小事实。
This is a fact within a fact. I was going to say, a little bit of a fact. What's happening? This episode, like I said, was written by Mike Schor, who was nominated for an Emmy Award for writing this episode. Oh, he should have won. Did he win? He did not. Oh, boo.
这是一个事实中的事实。我正想说，一个小事实。发生了什么？这一集，就像我说的，是由迈克·舒尔编写的，他因编写这一集而被提名为艾美奖。哦，他应该赢的。他赢了吗？他没有。哦，嘘。
He lost to Greg Daniels, who won for Gay Witch Hunt. Oh, okay, okay. You're all right with that. You're like, all right, the office one. Keep it in the family. That's right. Yay. All right.
他输给了格雷格·丹尼尔斯，后者凭借《同性恋女巫狩猎》获奖。哦，好吧，好吧。你对此没问题。你就像，好吧，《办公室》赢了。保持在家族内部。没错。耶。好吧。
Well, that was fun. All right. Well, now I'm going to give you fast fact number two. In this episode, you remember Michael says that he got tips on how to negotiate from Wikipedia. Yes. And some of the stuff that he says that he found on Wikipedia is stuff like you have to suddenly change the location or refuse to talk first. Yes. Well, we had a fan question from Breonna Kernan, Zui Wang, Charlie Altman, Shea Quiz, and Jeremy Sharp.
嗯，那很有趣。好吧。嗯，现在我要给你速记事实第二条。在这一集中，你记得迈克尔说他从维基百科上得到了关于如何谈判的建议。是的。他提到他在维基百科上发现的一些东西，比如你必须突然改变地点或拒绝先说话。是的。嗯，我们收到了来自布雷安娜·科南、瑞·王、查理·奥特曼、谢伊·奎兹和杰里米·夏普的粉丝提问。
They all asked, were the interview tips that Michael was using actually from Wikipedia, or did the writers make them up? Okay. None of that stuff was on Wikipedia, for real. The writers just made that up. Yeah, I, you know, Jen, I. I did a many deep dive on the art of negotiation for this episode. And I can confirm because I went to the actual Wikipedia page for negotiating. And those are not on there. Well, you know, after this episode aired, there was a major stir. Really? Fans started going on to the negotiation page of
他们都问，迈克尔使用的面试技巧真的是来自维基百科，还是编剧编出来的？好的。那些东西根本不在维基百科上，真的。编剧只是编出来的。是的，你知道，珍娜，我。我为这一集对谈判艺术进行了深度挖掘。我可以确认，因为我去了实际的维基百科谈判页面。那些不在上面。嗯，你知道，这一集播出后，引起了轩然大波。真的吗？粉丝们开始去谈判页面
Wikipedia and they started changing it to reflect Michael's advice. That's awesome. I mean, not. I mean, don't, don't be hackers, guys, but that's funny. And the administrators at Wikipedia had to put the page in, I guess, what is called semi-protection mode. And that limits who's allowed to edit a page. So any user that had an account that was less than four days old or anyone who's trying to put a post up as anonymous were forbidden. And then they had other administrators who would go in and delete all of the fake negotiation advice. That was just Michael Scott. Oh, my goodness, you guys. But it was a whole thing. There were like articles written about it in USA Today. Oh, wow.
维基百科，他们开始修改它以反映迈克尔的建议。那太棒了。我是说，不。我是说，别，别做黑客，伙计们，但这很有趣。维基百科的管理员不得不把页面设置成，我想，所谓的半保护模式。这限制了谁被允许编辑页面。所以任何拥有不到四天账户的用户或任何试图以匿名身份发帖的人都被禁止了。然后他们还有其他管理员会进去删除所有虚假的谈判建议。那只是迈克尔·斯科特。哦，天哪，你们。但这成了一件大事。甚至有关于它的文章写在《今日美国》上。哦，哇。
Yeah, it caused a stir. Stirring it up, office fans. I'm going through these quickly, Angela, because we have some exciting news, which is part of FastFact number three. Yes. This episode marks the return of Ed Helms as Andy Bernard, but it also marks the last regular appearance of Roy, played by David Denman. Now, Roy will continue to come back now and then, but this really officially ends the Pam Roy relationship.
是的，引起了轰动。搅动起来吧，《办公室》粉丝们。我很快地浏览这些，安吉拉，因为我们有一些令人兴奋的消息，这是速记事实第三条的一部分。是的。这一集标志着艾德·赫尔姆斯作为安迪·伯纳德的回归，但也标志着大卫·丹曼饰演的罗伊的最后一次常规出场。现在，罗伊会不时回来，但这真的正式结束了帕姆和罗伊的关系。
And we felt like we had to mark this occasion by talking to Roy himself, David Denman. And we had so much fun talking to him. Sam, can you play that interview? David Denman, hello. Welcome to office ladies. Hello, ladies. Hey, David, it's so good to see you. It's been a long time.
我们觉得我们必须通过采访罗伊本人，大卫·丹曼来纪念这个时刻。我们和他聊天非常开心。萨姆，你能播放那个采访吗？大卫·丹曼，你好。欢迎来到《办公室》女士。你好，女士们。嘿，大卫，见到你真好。好久不见了。
Yeah, it's been a long time. It has. Well, David, we always like to start by asking our guests how they came to be on the show. My buddy, who is an actor, a friend of mine in New York, he watched the British office and he called me and said, dude, you've got to watch the show. It's amazing. You're going to love it. There's nothing like it on TV. And I hear they're doing an American version. You've got to try to get in on that. So I watched it. And I was like, oh, my God, this is genius. And there was, you know, a couple of guys my age on the show. And I called my agent. I was like, hey, I hear they're doing
是的，好久不见了。确实。嗯，大卫，我们总是喜欢从询问嘉宾他们是如何来到这个节目的开始。我的哥们，他是一名演员，我在纽约的一个朋友，他看了英国版的《办公室》，他打电话给我说，伙计，你一定要看这个节目。太棒了。你会爱上它的。电视上没有像它这样的节目。我听说他们正在制作美国版。你一定要试着加入进去。所以我看了。我就想，哦，天哪，这真是天才。而且，你知道，节目里有几个和我年纪差不多的人。我打电话给我的经纪人。我说，嘿，我听说他们正在制作
an American version of the office. And he goes, yeah, yeah. And I go, I'd love to get in on that. And he goes, really? You want to do that? I go, yeah, what do you mean? Because I don't know. They're looking for improv comedians. And I'm like, yeah? You know, I went to Juilliard.
美国版的《办公室》。他说，是啊，是啊。我说，我很想加入进去。他说，真的吗？你想做那个？我说，是啊，你什么意思？因为我不知道。他们在寻找即兴喜剧演员。我说，是吗？你知道，我去了朱莉亚学院。
I did study improv along with Shakespeare and many other things. It's not just because I didn't go to, you know, Improv Olympic or whatever. It doesn't mean I don't have an interest in that. And don't have that in my toolbox. And he goes, oh, okay. So he called over and all the parts were cast except for Roy. And so I said, yeah, I'd love to go in for that part. That little thing changed my career.
我确实学习了即兴表演，还有莎士比亚和许多其他东西。这并不是因为我没有去，你知道，即兴奥林匹克之类的。并不意味着我没有兴趣。而且我的工具箱里没有那个。他说，哦，好吧。所以他打电话过去，除了罗伊之外，所有的角色都选好了。所以我说，是的，我很想去试那个角色。那件小事改变了我的职业生涯。
Well, David, I remember that you were one of the very, very first people cast. You were at our first original table read that Angela was not even at. They hadn't even filled out the rest of the office. It was just Steve, John, Rain, BJ, me, Phyllis, and you. That's who was at the first table read. And I remember Allison Jones brought her Polaroid camera and she took a Polaroid picture for each of us because she said that's a tradition of hers at Table Reeds for actors for their first series. Do you still have yours? I remember it's slightly different.
嗯，大卫，我记得你是最早被选中的人之一。你参加了我们最初的剧本围读，当时安吉拉甚至都没在场。他们甚至还没把办公室的其他角色填满。当时只有史蒂夫、约翰、雷恩、BJ、我、菲利斯和你。这就是第一次剧本围读时的所有人。我记得艾莉森·琼斯带了她的宝丽来相机，给我们每个人都拍了一张宝丽来照片，因为她说这是她为演员的第一部剧集进行剧本围读时的传统。你还留着你的那张吗？我记得它有点不一样。
I know she brought the Polaroid camera and she took a picture for herself that she did on every table read of her first show. And you said, ooh, I want one of those. She took another one and gave it to you. I don't think anyone else has any of those photos besides those two. Okay, that sounds like me. Thank you, David, because Jenna has talked about this. And thank you for setting that straight. Well, that explains why no one else has one but me.
我知道她带了宝丽来相机，她给自己也拍了一张，她在她第一部剧的每次剧本围读时都会这么做。然后你说，噢，我也想要一张。她又拍了一张给了你。除了那两张，我觉得没别人有那些照片了。好吧，这听起来确实像我。谢谢你，大卫，因为珍娜提到过这件事。谢谢你澄清了这一点。好吧，这就解释了为什么除了我之外没人有那张照片。
Yeah. Maybe you should stop asking that question, Jenna, to the original table read people. Oh, my gosh. Well, David, I just remember meeting you. and being so excited and we had that theater connection because I also got a theater degree. I just liked you immediately.
是啊。珍娜，也许你不该再问原始剧本围读成员那个问题了。天哪。好吧，大卫，我只记得见到你时非常兴奋，我们有那种戏剧上的联系，因为我也拿到了戏剧学位。我立刻就喜欢上你了。
I immediately liked you. No, we definitely hit it off. What was fun about that show in the beginning was you guys were all stuck in the office for hours and hours and hours. And usually when you film a series, it's like, oh, we'll shoot that scene and then we'll go shoot that scene.
我立刻就喜欢上你了。不，我们绝对是一拍即合。那部剧刚开始时有趣的地方在于，你们所有人都要在办公室里待上好几个小时。通常当你拍摄一部剧集时，就像是，噢，我们要拍那个场景，然后我们要去拍那个场景。
But because the way they filmed this with a documentary style where they whipped the camera across the whole office, office. They needed everyone to sit in the background all day long. So you guys would always be losing your mind by the time I showed up on the set. You were like, oh, oh, there's a new person. Hi. And you were very enthusiastic every time I got there. And I was very grateful for it. You know, so yeah, we definitely hit it off. I do remember Jenna coming to set, though, and being like, guess what I did this weekend? I was like, what? And she was like, I played poker with David.
但因为他们用纪录片风格拍摄，摄像机在整个办公室里扫来扫去，他们需要每个人整天坐在背景里。所以每次我出现在片场时，你们总是快要崩溃了。你们会说，噢，噢，有个新人。嗨。而且每次我到那儿，你们都非常热情。我对此非常感激。所以，是的，我们绝对是一拍即合。不过，我确实记得珍娜来到片场时说，猜猜我周末做了什么？我说，什么？她说，我和大卫打扑克了。
And I was like, what is happening? Where are you guys? You guys are like hanging out. You're playing poker in someone's garage? Like, what's this whole other life I need to get in on? I know. You never learned poker, Angela. You missed out on a lot. Well, you wouldn't want me at your poker table. I mean, I mean, one time I played with, and I had like a pair of threes and I thought I could win the whole thing. But I guess that's not, you know, I don't know. I'm not good at it, guys. Well, if we're playing for real money, we would want you at our poker table. No, you wouldn't because I'm the person that's like, all in. And everyone's like, wait, what's happening? I remember that, like, in Rain's garage, like, and here we are in a little poker table.
我就想，这是怎么回事？你们在哪儿？你们居然在一起玩？你们在某人的车库里打扑克？这是什么我需要加入的另一种生活吗？我知道。安吉拉，你从来没学过扑克，你错过了很多。好吧，你肯定不想让我上你的扑克桌。我的意思是，有一次我玩的时候，我有一对三，我以为我能赢下整局。但我想那不是，你知道，我不知道。伙计们，我不擅长这个。好吧，如果我们玩真钱的话，我们肯定想让你上我们的扑克桌。不，你们不会的，因为我是那种会说“全押”的人。然后每个人都会说，等等，发生了什么？我记得那是在雷恩的车库里，我们就在一张小扑克桌旁。
But I remember I took down a big pot opposite you, Jenna, once, and you lost your mind. You could not believe that I, that I had beat you in that hand. I don't think I ever won another hand against you. But that one just set the tongue. You were just so livid that I beat you. And do you remember that? That's my fond memory. I feel like I would often get dramatic when I lost and wasn't expecting it.
但我记得有一次我从你那里赢了一大笔筹码，珍娜，你当时都快疯了。你简直不敢相信我竟然在那手牌里赢了你。我觉得我之后再也没赢过你。但那一次确实奠定了基调。你当时因为我赢了你而非常愤怒。你还记得吗？那是我的美好回忆。我觉得我输了且没预料到的时候，经常会表现得很戏剧化。
So, David, Jenna and I have talked a little bit how we give our characters backstories. Like I would give Angela Martin reasons why she would react one way. And Jenna has shared her Pam backstory. And what was your take on Roy and Pam? Did you invent a backstory for their relationship and for Roy? Yeah, I did definitely have backstory. But I just, you know, I assume that these guys met and, high school. They started dating and, you know, they just kind of fell into this, you know,
所以，大卫，珍娜和我聊过一点我们是如何给角色设定背景故事的。比如我会给安吉拉·马丁设定她为什么会那样反应的理由。珍娜也分享了她的帕姆背景故事。你对罗伊和帕姆有什么看法？你为他们的关系和罗伊设定过背景故事吗？是的，我确实有背景故事。但我只是，你知道，我假设这些人是在高中认识的。他们开始约会，然后，你知道，他们就陷入了这种，你知道，
this dynamic where neither one of them, well, definitely, I don't even think Roy wanted to, you know, get married initially. I think it was just like, oh, this is what we're supposed to do next, and this was supposed to do next. And it wasn't until years later that, like, you know, when he was going to lose Pam, that, like, he was like, oh, I actually care about. this person, and I have to put some work into this. And, you know, with any relationship, you have to put some effort into it. And I don't think, I don't think Roy had ever thought about that until it was too late. And I went to a school with a bunch, with some, like, a couple of meatheads that I sort of fashioned this guy after. I mean, I'm not going to say who they were,
这种动态关系，他们俩谁都没有，嗯，绝对地，我甚至不认为罗伊最初想结婚。我觉得这就像是，噢，这是我们接下来该做的事，这是接下来该做的事。直到多年后，当他快要失去帕姆时，他才意识到，噢，我其实很在乎这个人，我必须为此付出努力。而且，你知道，任何关系，你都必须付出努力。我不认为，我不认为罗伊在为时已晚之前考虑过这一点。我和一群，和一些，像几个笨蛋一起上过学，我把这个家伙塑造成了他们那样。我的意思是，我不会说他们是谁，
but that's kind of where I saw Roy. And so I thought at the time, I was like, oh, this will be a great way to make fun of those guys. And then the next thing I know, I'm playing these parts for the rest of my life. That's not all. That's entirely true. Well, it's so funny because you,
但那就是我眼中罗伊的样子。所以当时我想，噢，这将是嘲笑那些家伙的好方法。然后接下来我知道的是，我余生都在扮演这些角色。那不是全部。那完全是真的。好吧，这太搞笑了，因为你，
I mean, like, knowing you, you're such, like, more of, like, an intellectual creative. Right? Thank you. I appreciate that. You're an outdoorsman, though. Like, that part of Roy fits you, I think.
我的意思是，了解你之后，你更像是一个知识分子型的创作者。对吧？谢谢。我很感激。不过你是个户外运动爱好者，我觉得罗伊的那部分很适合你。
Like, I mean, Roy is jet skiing, but, you know, you like the outdoors and stuff? I do. I do like the outdoors. I mean, I go out backpacking stuff like that. I don't know if Roy's necessarily that. He's more of like a let's get my RV and my jet ski and like hang out and drink some beers. Yeah.
我的意思是，罗伊会玩摩托艇，但你知道，你喜欢户外活动之类的？我喜欢。我确实喜欢户外活动。我的意思是，我会去背包旅行之类的。我不知道罗伊是否一定是那样。他更像是那种“让我们带上房车和摩托艇，去喝几杯啤酒”的人。是的。
And that's his outdoorsman. Right. He's going to load up a four-wheeler with a bunch of beer. Exactly. Probably make some bad choices in the wood. Yeah. Yeah. Well, David, I totally relate to how you can kind of fall into a casting rut because I just
那就是他的户外运动方式。没错。他会装上一辆四轮摩托车，带上一堆啤酒。完全正确。可能还会做一些在树林里的糟糕选择。是啊。是啊。好吧，大卫，我完全理解你怎么会陷入选角套路，因为我刚
did an interview yesterday, and the person interviewing me said, so Angela, you often play the heel. You're kind of a heel in everything. And I was like, yes, I have sort of made a way of playing the bitch or the weirdo. It's become my thing. It's hard for people to see you outside of that box once you're in it. And then like the success of the show is just continued on and on and on and on, which is fantastic, it's more popular now than it ever was. And, you know, if you're lucky enough to be part of something that, like, people enjoy and get into, and that's exciting. But to be part of something that gets into the culture of, that is so rare and so impossible to be a part of that. I'm constantly grateful every day that I got to be
昨天接受了一个采访，采访我的人说，安吉拉，你经常扮演反派。你在每部戏里都有点像个反派。我说，是的，我确实找到了一种扮演刻薄女或怪人的方式。这成了我的标志。一旦你进入那个框框，人们就很难在那个框框之外看到你。然后这部剧的成功一直持续下去，这太棒了，它现在比以往任何时候都更受欢迎。而且，你知道，如果你足够幸运能参与到人们喜欢并沉浸其中的事情中，那很令人兴奋。但能参与到一种融入文化的东西中，那是极其罕见的，几乎是不可能的。我每天都非常感激我能成为
that a little part part of the show because that's, you know, very, very, very rare. Yeah. So, David, at the beginning of season three, you came back to work and you were like super fit. We all noticed. Was this because you had done a movie roll over the summer
那个剧的一小部分，因为那，你知道，非常、非常、非常罕见。是的。所以，大卫，第三季开始时，你回到工作岗位，看起来超级健康。我们都注意到了。这是因为你夏天拍了一部电影吗？
and they wrote it into the plot? Or did Greg get you aside and tell you this idea that Roy should come back and be all excited to win Pam back. And you sort of transformed for the show. It was all for the show, but it was, and it was a conversation with Greg. I wouldn't say Greg said, hey, go get in shape. But he did say, he did take me aside and said, hey, I want, I got the, I'd like to make you more
他们把它写进了剧情里？还是格雷格把你拉到一边，告诉你这个想法，说罗伊应该回来，并且非常兴奋地想要赢回帕姆？你为了这部剧进行了某种蜕变。这完全是为了这部剧，但这是一个与格雷格的对话。我不会说格雷格说，嘿，去锻炼身体。但他确实说，他确实把我拉到一边说，嘿，我想要，我想要让你在下一季成为吉姆的竞争对手。我说，真的吗？他说，是的。我说，我不知道我们该怎么做。我的意思是，我们真的把这个家伙塑造成了一个笨蛋。我不知道还有谁会支持罗伊。他说，嗯，我想，我想，我想你可以做点什么让它奏效。我们也可以，你知道，写出来。所以我们给了他们那个机会。我说，好吧。我说，那我大概应该锻炼一下身体了。
of a rival of Jim's next season. I said, really? And he goes, yeah. I said, I don't know how we're going to do that. I mean, we've really made this guy such a knucklehead. I don't know how. anyone's going to root for Roy. And he goes, well, I think, I think, I think you can do something and make it work. When we can also, you know, write it. So we give them that opportunity. And I said, okay. I said, well, I probably should get in a shape then.
他说，好吧，如果你想的话。我们的一位摄像师，后来成了导演，你知道，我们的伙伴马特·索恩，他说，你应该参加这个铁人三项。我说，你疯了吗？我不参加铁人三项。我甚至，我几乎不跑步。我的意思是，他说，你能做到的。我告诉你，你能做到的。我说，不，不，那永远不会发生。
He goes, okay, if you want to. And one of our camera operators, who became a director, you know, our buddy Matt Sown, he was like, you should do this triathlon. And I was like, are you out of your mind? I'm not doing a triathlon. I don't even, I barely run. I mean, he was like, you can do it. I'm telling you, you could do it. And I'm like, no, no, that's never going to happen.
我的意思是，我高中时打过水球，大概是大一的时候。所以我游泳游得很好，我不担心那个，但我从来没骑过自行车。他说，我知道伙计，我可以给你弄辆自行车。而且，你应该去试试。而且，你知道，就像那次对话，格雷格想要让罗伊成为更多竞争对手的想法，让这一切都动了起来。所以我开始为马里布铁人三项训练，我最终参加了大概10年，我想，每年都参加。
I mean, I played water polo in high school for like my freshman year. So I was a pretty good swimmer. I wasn't worried about that, but I hadn't ever been on a bike. And he was like, I know guys, I can get you a bike. And like, you should just do it. And, you know, it was like that conversation with, Greg's idea of trying to make, you know, Roy more of a rival just kind of put it all into motion. And so I started training for the Malibu Triathlon, which I ended up doing like 10, I did that for like 10 years, I think, every year.
办公室里还有很多人也加入了。我不知道你们俩有没有参加过。我从来没参加过，但我记得这个，大卫。我记得剧组里的很多男士和一些女士也是。特里·温伯格，对吧？特里·温伯格非常健康。她真的全力以赴了。我每年都能看到她在那里。她现在还在做。你们回来时带着照片，那真是太不可思议了。是的。而且它总是和艾美奖在同一个周末，就像是，人们早上参加铁人三项，然后去换衣服，晚上去参加艾美奖派对，这对我来说太搞笑了。我想，那太累了。好吧，大卫，我本来很乐意参加的，但安吉拉认为我没有运动天赋。不，那根本不是真的。谢谢。
And so many other people from the office got joined in on that. I don't know if you, if either of you guys ever did it. I never did it, but I remember this, David. I remember a bunch of the guys on the crew and some of the women as well. Terry Weinberg, right? Terry Weinberg is like so fit. She really went all out. I see her out there every year. She still does it. You guys would come back with photos and it was incredible. Yeah. And it was always the same weekend as the Emmys, which is like, people like go do the, go do the triathlon in the morning and then go change and go to an Emmy party that night, which was hilarious to me. I'm like, that's so much. Well, I would have loved to have done that, David, but Angela doesn't think I have the athleticism. Now, that's not true at all. Thank you.
请大声清楚地告诉“办公室女士”的听众们。我需要听到你对这个论点的支持，大卫。首先，安吉拉，你必须记住这一点。我不想让你难堪，但还记得珍娜决定锻炼身体的那一年吗？她说，我正在做。我正在做。我说，为你感到高兴。她登上了《Shape》杂志的封面，穿着比基尼。她看起来棒极了。
Say it loud and clear for the office ladies' audience, please. I need to hear your support for this argument, David. First of all, do you, you, Angela, you have to remember this. And I hate to put you on what point, but remember the year that Jenna decided to get into shape and was like, and she was like, I'm doing it. I am doing it. And I'm like, good for you. And she was on the cover of like shape magazine and a bikini. And she looked phenomenal.
她看起来棒极了。大卫，这就是我想对你说的。我的论点不是珍娜不能锻炼身体。当她想锻炼身体时，这个女人是非常硬核的。你知道，她还制作了一张名为《斯克兰顿之声》的混音带。她写了一份关于帕姆背景的三页文档。当她想锻炼身体时，天哪，她真的会去锻炼。但她能做侧手翻和后空翻，还能在空中扔手榴弹，
She looked phenomenal. David, here is what I'm saying to you. My argument is not that Jenna cannot get into shape. When she wants to get into shape, the woman is hardcore. You know, she also made a mixtape called Sounds of Scranton. She wrote a three-page document about the background of Pam. When she wants to get in a shape, by God, she gets in shape. But could she do a cartwheel and a backflip and throw a grenade in the air
然后跳上一根绳子，在停车场荡过去吗？但我见过她带着吉他穿过机场，大卫。我见过她试图把吉他带上飞机。好吧。看，关于把吉他带上飞机或者在停车场做后空翻、荡绳子，我收回前言，我不知道。就像，她会成为下一个劳拉·克劳馥吗？可能，可能不会。
and then jump on a rope and swing across a parking lot? But I've seen her carry a guitar through an airport, David. I saw her try to get a guitar on a plane. Okay. Look, I stand corrected in regards to getting a guitar on a plane or doing a backflip through a parking lot, swinging on a rope, and I don't know. Like, is she going to be the next Laura Croft? Probably, probably not.
这就是我的观点，大卫。她可以参加铁人三项。我只是这么说。我，听着，我没说她不能参加铁人三项。珍娜跳出来想让我难堪，并试图把你拉到她那边。我认为她可以参加铁人三项。随便吧。我觉得她会是团队领袖。
This is my point, David. She could do a triathlon. That's all I'm saying. I, listen, I didn't say she couldn't do a triathlon. Jenna jumped in to give me shade and tried to get you on her side. I think she could do a triathlon. Whatever. I think she'd be the team leader.
她会给每个人安排时间表。我毫无疑问。随便吧。噢，天哪。讽刺。我们这儿有点讽刺意味。好吧。那么，我有一个关于这次采访的问题。
She'd have everyone on a schedule. No doubt in my mind. Whatever. Oh, Lord. Sass. We got some sass happening. All right. Well, I have a question for this interview.
我正在移动。太久了。大卫，总的来说，你在剧组期间有什么最喜欢的场景吗？有什么你因为任何原因而特别喜欢的吗？我确实有一个特别记得的时刻，但那不是在镜头前的。我们当时在拍摄“酒船”那一集。那是一个漫长的夜晚。第二天早上，当我们结束拍摄时，他们有一艘浮筒船。史蒂夫和我跳上浮筒船，在太阳升起时飞驰过长滩港。那感觉，太棒了。出于某种原因，我记得那一刻胜过我在那部剧里的任何其他时刻。我喜欢那个。
I'm moving. have so long. David, in general, do you have any favorite scenes from your time on the show? Anything you just loved for any reason? I do have a moment that I remember specifically, but it wasn't anything that was on camera. We were shooting the Booz Cruise episode. It was a long night. And the next morning, like we, as we were rapping, they had a pontoon boat. And Steve and I jumped in the pontoon boat and we blazed through, Long Beach Harbor as the sun was coming up. And it was like, it was awesome. And I just for some reason remember that moment of my time on that show more than anything else. I love that.
好吧，大卫，我只是想听听你对安吉拉和罗伊这件事的看法，因为网上有很多人在讨论。有一个Reddit帖子说安吉拉和罗伊有一段秘密恋情。我们和格雷格谈过这件事。格雷格说，我，也许他如果能在剧里待得更久，但没有，我不这么认为。但我们可以看出罗伊为什么会吸引安吉拉，那种高大、勇敢的家伙。我记得，你会选谁？我觉得罗伊当时想的是，是的，她很火辣。
Well, David, I just want to get your take on the whole Angela and Roy thing because there's a lot of people online. There's like a Reddit thread that Angela and Roy were having some secret love affair. We talked to Greg about it. Greg was like, I'm, maybe he had stayed on the show longer, but no, I don't think so. But we could see where Roy would appeal to Angela, sort of this big, gallant fella. I remember that, like, who would you do? I think Roy was like, yeah, she's hot.
我不，我不，就像格雷格说的，我想如果他能在剧里待得更久，那会是一个有趣的转折，可以制造冲突。为了报复而在帕姆面前和安吉拉约会会有多有趣？噢，噢，是的。
I don't, I don't, like Greg said, I think if he'd been on the show, if I'd been on the show longer, that would have been a fun, you know, twist to throw in there to just create conflict. How much fun would it have been to revenge date Angela? in front of Pam. Oh, oh, yeah.
噢，不，百分之百。那会是，我绝对会参与其中。我相信罗伊也会参与其中的。噢，那会很有趣。是的。好吧，大卫，你和克雷格·罗宾逊有很多对手戏。你提到过我们在办公室待了很长时间，
Oh, no, 100%. That would have been, that would have totally been into that. And Roy would have been into that, too, I'm sure. Oh, that would have been funny. Yeah. Well, David, you got to have a lot of scenes with Craig Robinson. You sort of mentioned that we spent a lot of time in the office,
但你拍了所有那些仓库场景，而且你们俩经常被安排在一起。你有什么和克雷格合作的故事，或者那是什么感觉吗？我爱那个家伙。像你一样，我和他相处得非常好，在刚开始的时候，我们在工作之外也经常聚在一起。我试图让他参加铁人三项，但他不感兴趣。但我们差点参加了“泥巴伙伴”，那是一种疯狂的比赛，你要去跑障碍赛。而且你会，我的意思是，真的，你和搭档或多人一起完成，你们互相帮助爬过这些障碍。
but you got to do all those warehouse scenes, and oftentimes the two of you were paired up. Do you have any stories from working with Craig or what that was like? I love that dude. Like you, I got along with him really well and we hung out outside of work quite a bit at the beginning. And I was trying to get him to do the triathlon, which he was not into. But we almost did almost a muddy buddy, which is this like crazy race where you like go on this obstacle course. And you get, I mean, literally, you like, you do it with a partner or multiple people and you help each other like climb across these obstacle courses.
你穿过泥潭。你会被电击，这简直太疯狂了。电击？是的。什么？为什么？是的。这听起来像是一场糟糕的兄弟会入会仪式。
You go through mud. You get electrocuted like it's the most insane. Electrooted? Yeah. What? Why? Yeah. This sounds like a bad frat hazing.
是的。这听起来像是一场糟糕的兄弟会入会仪式。不，这太可怕了。我做过一次，我再也不会做了。但任何参加过的人都知道，有一个障碍赛，你必须在泥地上爬行，他们有这些悬挂的电流，一旦它们碰到你的身体，
Yeah. This sounds like a bad frat hazing. It's not, it is horrible. And I did it once and I'll never, ever do it again. But anyone who's ever participated, they know there's this one obstacle course where you have to crawl on the ground on your, through the. mud and they have these hanging like electric currents that like once they touch your body
它们就会电你，这是为了让你保持低姿势，但当你像我这么大块头时，你就会被一次又一次地电击，这是有史以来最糟糕的事情。克雷格和我，我们一直谈论这件事，我们当时非常有可能
they zap you and like it's to keep you down low but when you're as big as I am you just get zapped over and over and over again it was the worst thing ever Craig and I like we talked about it all the time we were going to we were so possibly going to
去做那个，也许他只是在对我客气，说也许我会考虑一下。百分之百。他是。我觉得他完全是在安抚你。是啊，伙计。那听起来是个好主意。再见。
do that maybe he just was just being nice to me saying maybe I'll think about it 100% He was. I think he was totally placating you. Yeah, man. That sounds like a great idea. Blu-bye.
是的。噢，我喜欢那个。那是我的幻想，我和克雷格一起去进行那些冒险之一。现在我太老了。我不想做了。这太疯狂了。我20年前就不想做。我不想被电击。
Yeah. Oh, I love that. That's my fantasy that Craig and I would have done one of those adventures together. Now I'm too old. I don't want to do it. It's nuts. I don't want to do it 20 years ago. I don't want to be zapped.
现在，在这一集中，大卫，我们在饥饿狐狸餐厅有一个场景，这算是帕姆和罗伊很长一段时间以来的最后一场大戏，因为你确实回来了，我们后来还有另一次交心。但这暂时结束了这一切。我记得和你拍摄这个场景时感到有点情绪化，因为我知道你在办公室的常规时间要结束了。你有什么记忆吗？格雷格和你谈过这件事吗？
Now, on this episode, David, we have this scene at the Hungry Fox Diner. and it's kind of Pam and Roy's last big scene together for a while because you do come back and we have another kind of heart to heart it later. But this ends it for a while. And I remember shooting this scene with you and feeling kind of emotional because I knew that your regular time on the office was ending. Do you have any memories from that? Did Greg talk to you about that?
大卫，在这一集中，我们在饥饿狐狸餐厅有这样一场戏。这算是帕姆和罗伊在很长一段时间里最后一场重要的对手戏了，因为你确实还会回来，我们之后还有一次推心置腹的谈话。但这暂时为他们的关系画上了句号。我记得和你拍这场戏时，心里挺感慨的，因为我知道你在《办公室》的常驻时间要结束了。你对那场戏有什么记忆吗？格雷格和你谈过这件事吗？
I'll tell you like when I found out. out. We did a table read. And right then, Craig got the phone call or right before that you guys had all got picked up for two more seasons. Or maybe it was three seasons. I don't know how many seasons it was at that point. But everyone was like, oh, my God. Yay! And I was sitting right next to Greg and I turned to Greg and I go, I'm not coming back, am I? And he goes, no. He goes, but it's not you. I just got to get Romeo and Julia together. And I just don't feel like I can do that with you here. but I don't want to kill you off because I want you to come back and I said I get it and the coolest thing ever
我告诉你我是什么时候发现的。我们当时在围读剧本。就在那时，或者在那之前，克雷格接到了电话，你们所有人都被续订了两季。或者可能是三季。我不记得当时是几季了。但每个人都说，天哪，太棒了！我当时就坐在格雷格旁边，我转过头对他说，我不会再回来了，对吧？他说，是的。他说，但这不怪你。我只是得把罗密欧与朱丽叶凑在一起。我觉得有你在场我做不到这一点。但我不想把你写死，因为我希望你回来。我说我明白了，这是有史以来最酷的事情。
was like I said would it be okay for me to do like a pilot or something because it was right at the beginning of pilot season he goes yeah I think that would be okay and you know oftentimes because they don't want people
就像我说的那样，我问我能不能去试镜试播集之类的，因为那正好是试播集季节的开始，他说，是的，我想那应该没问题。你知道，通常情况下，因为他们不想让别人
to know something's not going to happen they won't let you do that like you're under contract and so they're not going to allow you to do another show and so he was very gracious to let me do that and I ended up getting this really great pilot that ended up not going, but it was a big get for me
知道某件事不会发生，他们不会让你那样做，因为你有合同在身，所以他们不会允许你参加另一部剧。所以他非常大度地让我去做了。我最终得到了一个非常棒的试播集，虽然最后没能播出，但对我来说是一个巨大的收获。
and definitely changed the trajectory of my career. Shortly after that, we did shoot this episode, and I knew that I was leaving the show, and it was definitely, it was emotional for me too, because we become really good friends, you know? And I just knew that, like, it was coming to an end. Like, we did stay friends afterwards, but we didn't see each other as often.
这绝对改变了我职业生涯的轨迹。在那之后不久，我们拍摄了这一集，我知道我要离开这部剧了，这对我来说绝对是情绪化的，因为我们成了非常好的朋友，你知道吗？我只是知道，这一切都要结束了。我们之后确实保持了朋友关系，但我们见面的次数没那么频繁了。
You're working, and I'm off doing other things, and, you know, you just end up becoming friends with the people you're working with. And that's just the way life goes on these shows. But, yeah, it was definitely emotional because I definitely felt like, you know, this cast, you know, you become a family. So, yeah, it was definitely emotional for me to shoot that last scene. David, did you take anything from set when you wrapped? Do you have a memento? You know, it's funny, I don't, but I have, I don't know if you guys remember this,
你在工作，而我在忙别的事情，你知道，你最终会和你一起工作的人成为朋友。这就是这些剧集里的生活方式。但是，是的，这绝对是情绪化的，因为我确实觉得，你知道，这个剧组，你就像变成了一家人。所以，是的，拍摄最后一场戏对我来说绝对是情绪化的。大卫，你杀青的时候从片场拿走什么东西了吗？你有纪念品吗？你知道，很有趣，我没有，但我有，我不知道你们还记不记得，
but like the jacket that all of the warehouse wears was my jacket that I auditioned with. No. Yeah, yeah. It was a, I bought this jacket from Old Navy and I wore it to my audition. And Greg said, I want that jacket. What is that jacket?
仓库里所有人穿的那件夹克就是我试镜时穿的那件。不是吧。是的，是的。那是我从Old Navy买的夹克，我穿着它去试镜。格雷格说，我想要那件夹克。那是什么夹克？
And it kind of looks like a dicky jacket, but it wasn't. It was this like, you know, like warehouse jacket that Old Navy made. And so poor costumes had to call Old Navy. They called me and they're like, where'd you get that jacket? I have to get it because Greg says everyone has to wear that. So then they bought every, every, you know, every thing they could get in stock of Old Navy's
它看起来有点像迪基夹克，但并不是。它就是那种Old Navy做的仓库夹克。所以可怜的服装组不得不给Old Navy打电话。他们给我打电话说，你在哪买的那件夹克？我必须得买到它，因为格雷格说每个人都必须穿那件。所以他们把Old Navy库存里能买到的所有夹克都买下来了。
jacket. So I have that original jacket. I don't wear it anymore. I have it somewhere. Can you imagine if you put that jacket on and Jenna, the two of you met for lunch? Just you and you in that jacket and like Jenna with her hair half up, half down, people would be like, well, David, thank you so much. It was really, really good. Good to see you and reminisce. Well, David, what are you up to now that we can talk about here? Well, I finished this a while ago. It got pushed because of COVID, but I did this movie, Greenland, that's out with Jared Butler and Marina Bacherin that I think will be in theaters by the time this airs.
所以我保留了那件原版夹克。我不再穿它了。我把它放在某个地方。你能想象如果你穿上那件夹克，然后珍娜，你们俩去吃午饭吗？就你穿着那件夹克，珍娜梳着半扎发，人们会说，好吧，大卫，非常感谢。真的很高兴见到你并叙叙旧。那么，大卫，你现在在忙什么我们可以聊聊的吗？嗯，我很久以前就完成了这个。因为新冠疫情推迟了，但我拍了一部电影《格陵兰》，和杰拉德·巴特勒、莫瑞娜·巴卡琳主演，我想这部电影播出时应该已经在影院上映了。
It's like a disaster movie. It's really good. I play a really, really fun character. I don't want to say anything about it. And I'm doing this series called Mayor of East Town with Kate Winslet that we were in the middle of filming. And it's amazing. Holy, David. That's amazing.
这是一部灾难片。非常棒。我扮演了一个非常非常有趣的角色。我不想透露太多。我正在拍摄一部名为《东城梦魇》的剧集，和凯特·温斯莱特合作，我们正在拍摄中。这太棒了。天哪，大卫。那太棒了。
She's awesome. It's great. Well, I'm so excited for you. Kate Winslet is one of my idols. So can we please go out for drinks when you get back? I will be happy to do that. I'd love to get drinks to be fun. David, thank you.
她太棒了。这很棒。我真为你感到兴奋。凯特·温斯莱特是我的偶像之一。所以你回来后我们能一起去喝一杯吗？我很乐意。我很想去喝一杯，那会很有趣。大卫，谢谢你。
Thank you so much. It's so wonderful to see you. And I can't wait to see all the things. that you're up to. They sound so wonderful. Thank you, guys. So good to see you. Thanks, David. Hit pause on whatever you're listening to and hit play on your next adventure.
非常感谢。见到你真是太好了。我迫不及待地想看你正在做的所有事情。听起来都很棒。谢谢你们。很高兴见到你们。谢谢，大卫。暂停你正在听的内容，开始你的下一次冒险吧。
This fall get double points on every qualified stay. Life's the trip. Make the most of it at Best Western. Visit bestwestern.com for complete terms and conditions. when you switch to a Scotia Bank banking package. Learn more at scotiabank.com slash banking packages. Conditions apply. Scotia Bank, you're richer than you think. Angela, that was so great getting to talk to David.
今年秋天，每次符合条件的住宿都能获得双倍积分。生活就是一场旅行。在最佳西方酒店尽情享受吧。访问bestwestern.com了解完整的条款和条件。当你切换到丰业银行的银行套餐时。在scotiabank.com/bankingpackages了解更多信息。适用条件。丰业银行，你比你想象的更富有。安吉拉，和大卫聊天真是太棒了。
I know. We're just having the best time getting to see everyone from the show. But lady, are you ready to tackle this episode? Because a lot happens. Oh, and it happens fast. Guys, this episode opens with Roy pacing outside in the parking lot. It's kind of like he's waiting, I think, for Jim to come out of the building, but Jim's not coming out of the building. Yeah, it's the end of the day.
我知道。能见到剧组里的每个人真是太开心了。但是，女士，你准备好处理这一集了吗？因为发生了很多事。哦，而且发生得很快。伙计们，这一集以罗伊在停车场外踱步开始。我觉得他好像在等吉姆从大楼里出来，但吉姆并没有出来。是的，那是下班时间。
And Jim and Karen are kind of, they're flirting, kind of making their plans, what they're going to do. And Roy gets tired of waiting in the parking lot and he comes on up inside. Yeah, he just, he bursts in, he yells for Jim. and Pam is like, oh, no. Well, did you notice Jim right away looks right to you? Like, oh, crap. Yeah. And then a lot happens.
吉姆和凯伦在调情，在计划他们要做什么。罗伊等得不耐烦了，就走进了大楼。是的，他冲了进来，大喊吉姆的名字。帕姆心想，哦，不。好吧，你注意到吉姆第一时间看向你了吗？就像，哦，糟糕。是的。然后发生了很多事。
So Roy lunges at Jim. Jim just shoves Karen out of the way. He's like, I got to get Karen out of this line of danger. And right before Roy gets his hands on Jim, Dwight pops up and just. pepper sprays Roy in the face. I mean, Dwight doesn't just spray him. He, like, douses him with the whole container, and it clearly starts to affect everyone in the
罗伊向吉姆猛扑过去。吉姆一把将凯伦推开。他心想，我得让凯伦远离危险。就在罗伊抓住吉姆之前，德怀特跳了出来，直接把胡椒喷雾喷在罗伊脸上。我的意思是，德怀特不仅仅是喷了他。他几乎把整罐都倒在他身上了，这显然开始影响到办公室里的每个人。
bullpen. Well, I remember Jeff Blitz talking to us about this. We had a whole conversation where he was like, listen, it's not just the person who gets hit that suffers the consequences of pepper spray going off. Like, it's a, it's a mist that will affect people in a general radius, and they did a bunch a research on it. And I remember us talking about what happens when you get pepper sprayed. And so that's why I was like, okay, well, I'm going to pick up a tissue and I'm going to hold it to my eyes. And we were all blinking and kind of coughing. Yeah, I believe it. Well, Angela, we had a fan
嗯，我记得杰夫·布里茨和我们谈过这件事。我们进行了一次完整的对话，他说，听着，不仅仅是那个被喷的人会承受胡椒喷雾的后果。这是一种会影响周围半径内人们的雾气，他们对此做了很多研究。我记得我们讨论过被胡椒喷雾喷到会发生什么。所以这就是为什么我说，好吧，我要拿一张纸巾捂住眼睛。我们都在眨眼，还在咳嗽。是的，我相信。好吧，安吉拉，我们有一个粉丝
question about this scene from Lila Dano, who is 11 years old. Hi, Lila. As well as from Catherine M. Anna C. Stephanie T. Chloe J. and Hannah S. They all asked, what did Dwight actually spray Roy with? Because, I mean, obviously we didn't pepper spray David Denman. Well, that's a good question. And I was wondering it as well. I wonder if you had some Kentapedia or Phil Shea info for us. I did ask Kentapedia about this. And Kent said that it was an Evian water bottle sprayer. Oh, well, that's some good acting then, you guys. Yeah. Yeah. You just got misted, basically. You basically went to the spa, an aggressive spa. Yes, exactly.
关于这一幕的问题，来自11岁的莱拉·达诺。你好，莱拉。还有凯瑟琳·M、安娜·C、斯蒂芬妮·T、克洛伊·J和汉娜·S。她们都问，德怀特到底是用什么喷罗伊的？因为，显然我们没有真的对大卫·丹曼喷胡椒喷雾。嗯，这是个好问题。我也很好奇。我想知道你有没有什么“肯塔百科”或菲尔·谢的信息给我们。我确实问过肯塔百科。肯说那是依云矿泉水喷雾瓶。哦，那你们的演技真好。是的。是的。你基本上只是被喷了水雾。你基本上是去了一趟水疗中心，一个激进的水疗中心。是的，完全正确。
Well, we had some other people write in. Nitya G. Aaron W., Gustavo G., Brianna L. and Carly G. All asked how much choreography went into filming the opening scene when Roy tries to punch Jim. How many takes were needed to get it done? And Kent told me that we did, and I remember this, Ang, about a dozen takes of Roy just rushing in and we got everyone's reactions and we staged that all out before we ever even got out the spray. And then we only did a couple of takes where we actually sprayed. And everything was overseen by a stunt. coordinator and our stunt coordinator's name was
嗯，还有其他人写信来。尼蒂亚·G、亚伦·W、古斯塔沃·G、布里安娜·L和卡莉·G。都问拍摄开场戏时，罗伊试图打吉姆的那一段编排了多少动作。拍了多少条才完成？肯告诉我，我们拍了——我记得这个，安——大约十几条罗伊冲进来的镜头，我们捕捉了每个人的反应，在喷雾之前我们就把这些都排练好了。然后我们只拍了几条真正喷雾的镜头。一切都由特技协调员监督，我们的特技协调员叫
Bobby Porter. I remember Bobby Porter. Yeah. He was so sweet. Well, you know, Kevin and Angela aren't there. They're not there. Oh, that's right. So you would not have remembered that. No, we weren't there. So, but, you know, obviously, Angela has many questions about this moment. We'll get to that. Yes, she does. Jenna, now we're into the episode and this is just one of my favorite scenes. Michael is talking to Jan on speaker.
鲍比·波特。我记得鲍比·波特。是的。他太可爱了。嗯，你知道，凯文和安吉拉不在那里。他们不在那里。哦，对了。所以你不会记得那个。不，我们不在那里。所以，但是，你知道，显然，安吉拉对这一刻有很多疑问。我们会谈到的。是的，她有。珍娜，现在我们进入这一集了，这是我最喜欢的场景之一。迈克尔正在用免提电话和简通话。
microphone. Toby is there. Jan is like, is Toby there? Michael says no. And Toby's like, I'm right here, Jan. And so Toby sort of updates Jan that Jim isn't going to press charges. They're going to let Roy go. But because Roy is leaving the warehouse, Darrell now wants a race. He wants to renegotiate his job, right? Yeah. And this is going to prove to be problematic. And Jan says to Michael, are you going to handle this? And this couplet of dialogue is one of my favorites. Sam, can you play it? Do you care of this? Yeppers.
托比也在那里。简问，托比在吗？迈克尔说不在。托比说，我就在这儿，简。于是托比告诉简，吉姆不打算起诉。他们打算放过罗伊。但因为罗伊要离开仓库，达里尔现在想要加薪。他想重新协商他的工作，对吧？是的。这被证明是有问题的。简问迈克尔，你要处理这件事吗？这一对对话是我最喜欢的。萨姆，你能播放一下吗？你关心这个吗？Yeppers（是的）。
What did I tell you about yeppers? I don't remember. I told you not to say it. Do you remember that? Yes. Jenna, I love this so much. I had to rewatch it a few times because this is a window into their rules. relationship. And I love the Jan Michael dynamic so much. How many times has he said
我跟你说过多少次不要说Yeppers？我不记得了。我告诉过你不要说它。你记得吗？是的。珍娜，我太喜欢这个了。我不得不重看了好几次，因为这是他们关系的窗口。我太喜欢简和迈克尔的互动了。他在家里
yeppers to her at home in their condo? How many times has he said it in the car or whatever they're doing? And she has had it with yeppers. Yepers is done. And she really doesn't want to have to say it again. How many times have I told you not to say yeppers? Yeesh. Okay. Do you have a word that, like, triggers you like that? Have you had a relationship where someone says something or a friendship? Oh, that's a good question. Do you? Well, I actually have had someone in my life, no names mentioned, that has said, Anywho. Interesting. And let me tell you, anywho, repeated over and over, it can make you snap. I don't love the phrase brain fart. I don't, I don't love when people say, oh, I had a brain fart.
对她说过多少次Yeppers？他在车里或者做其他事情时说过多少次？她已经受够了Yeppers。Yeppers结束了。她真的不想再说了。我告诉过你多少次不要说Yeppers？哎呀。好吧。你有没有一个词，像那样会触发你的情绪？你有没有过一段关系，或者一段友谊，有人总是说某个词？哦，这是个好问题。你有吗？嗯，我生命中确实有一个人，不提名字，总是说“Anywho”（无论如何）。有趣。我告诉你，Anywho被反复说，真的会让你抓狂。我不喜欢“brain fart”（脑子短路）这个词。我不喜欢人们说，哦，我脑子短路了。
Why? I don't know why. I just don't love it. Well, listen, after this, Angela, Pam has this talking head. There's this kind of a series of talking heads. Pam says, you know, she doesn't want to be rude, but she would prefer not to comment on what happened. But it sucked. And at the end of that talking head, I feel like I smirk a little bit.
为什么？我不知道为什么。我就是不喜欢。好吧，听着，在这之后，安吉拉，帕姆有这一段独白。有一系列独白。帕姆说，你知道，她不想粗鲁，但她不想评论发生的事情。但这太糟糕了。在那段独白的最后，我觉得我露出了一个小小的冷笑。
Did you notice this? we had people write in about it. They were like, why does she kind of smirk at the end? She says it sucked, but is she smirking because she kind of liked it in some way? You guys, I'm Pam and I was completely thrown by this performance choice. I don't know what I was doing there. I mean, I sort of thought you were like trying to shrug it off. Like, it sucked.
你注意到了吗？有人写信问这件事。他们问，为什么她最后露出了那种冷笑？她说这很糟糕，但她冷笑是因为她某种程度上喜欢它吗？伙计们，我是帕姆，我完全被这个表演选择搞糊涂了。我不知道我当时在做什么。我的意思是，我以为你是在试图摆脱它。就像，这太糟糕了。
You know how like when people are really uncomfortable, sometimes they smile? Yeah, I think that's what I was doing. Yeah. I certainly was not intending to make you think that Pam liked it. No, she was really uncomfortable by it. I think so uncomfortable that she doesn't even quite know how to relate, relay it in the moment. It's like someone with a nervous laughter. Yeah, she's, she's embarrassed, and we're going to see later in the episode.
你知道当人们感到非常不舒服时，有时会微笑吗？是的，我想我当时就是那样。是的。我当然不是想让你觉得帕姆喜欢它。不，她对此感到非常不舒服。我想她太不舒服了，以至于她甚至不知道该如何在那一刻表达出来。就像有人在紧张地笑。是的，她很尴尬，我们稍后会在这一集中看到。
Like, she is truly embarrassed by this. I love this episode so much, and I feel like Mike Scher really, really delivered on some dialogue. In particular, I loved when. Jim was trying to thank Dwight. He just wanted to thank him. And Rain has great dialogue as Dwight. He says, thank you, not necessary. That's not accepted. Don't want it. Won't open it. Don't need it. Won't take it. He's got this really fun runner of how he is responding to Jim just simply trying to say thank you. Yeah. And Jim is going to keep trying to show his appreciation through this episode and Dwight will not have it. No. Well, now, Angela, we get to a scene that
她确实对此感到非常尴尬。我太喜欢这一集了，我觉得迈克·谢尔在对话上真的表现得非常出色。特别是，我喜欢吉姆试图感谢德怀特的时候。他只是想感谢他。雷恩作为德怀特有很棒的台词。他说，谢谢，没必要。不接受。不想要。不会打开它。不需要。不会拿。他有一个非常有趣的梗，关于他如何回应吉姆试图说谢谢。是的。吉姆在这一集中会一直试图表达他的感激之情，而德怀特就是不领情。不。好吧，现在，安吉拉，我们来到了一个场景，
I love so much and we got a lot of mail about. Okay. This is when Oscar gives Angela Roy's check and says Roy will be coming to pick this up later this afternoon. Kevin is really bummed that he missed the fight and Angela says to Oscar, yeah, I missed it too. Could you, could you describe it? And so Oscar explains the fight and Dwight's heroism. How can we describe it? It has a real effect on Angela.
我非常喜欢，我们收到了很多邮件。好的。这是奥斯卡给安吉拉罗伊的支票，并说罗伊今天下午晚些时候会来取。凯文很遗憾错过了这场打斗，安吉拉问奥斯卡，是的，我也错过了。你能描述一下吗？于是奥斯卡解释了这场打斗和德怀特的英雄主义。我们该怎么描述它呢？这对安吉拉产生了真正的影响。
I mean, guys, let's just call it out. She's totally turned on by this moment of, like, gallant behavior by Dwight and Roy. I don't know what's happening. The whole interaction clearly does it for her. You have to remember in season five down the road, blood drive, we learn that Angela has had two men duel over her. Yeah. So she has a thing. for these dueling fellas. Mike's sure, I feel like always like to put my character in these
我的意思是，伙计们，我们直说吧。她完全被德怀特和罗伊这种英勇的行为所吸引。我不知道发生了什么。整个互动显然让她很兴奋。你必须记住，在第五季的后面，在“献血”那一集中，我们了解到安吉拉曾有两个男人为她决斗。是的。所以她对这些决斗的家伙有种特殊的情结。我觉得迈克·谢尔总是喜欢把我的角色放在这些
really, like, throws of emotion, whether she was incredibly upset or aroused or her pissed off. Like, I feel like he liked to see her journey through that. Yes. Well, she's not a very emotionally showy person. And I think Mike liked to play with that a little bit. Well, we certainly had a lot of fun. I remember when we were doing this. episode having conversations with Jeff Blitz and Mike about how much of her hand would she tip, right? Like how much would she really show? And that was really fun to play around with. I did some takes where I reacted a little bit bigger, some a little smaller, and just finding those nuances was so much fun for me as an actor. Well, we had a fan catch, Angela, from Madeline Weber
非常强烈的情绪中，无论是她极其沮丧、兴奋还是愤怒。我觉得他喜欢看她经历这些。是的。嗯，她不是一个情绪外露的人。我觉得迈克喜欢玩弄这一点。嗯，我们当然玩得很开心。我记得我们在拍这一集时，和杰夫·布里茨以及迈克讨论过她会透露多少情绪，对吧？她会表现出多少？这真的很有趣。我拍了一些反应稍微大一点的镜头，一些小一点的，作为演员，找到这些细微差别对我来说太有趣了。好吧，安吉拉，我们有一个粉丝捕捉到了，来自玛德琳·韦伯
and Greg Rodriguez. They said around four minutes, 30 seconds, Angela, appears to be rubbing a heart-shaped necklace while Oscar talks about Dwight's heroic actions. Do you think that this necklace was given to Angela by Dwight? Any thoughts on that, Angela? I have never thought about that. It was actually, if I remember, kind of like a tiny locket. Mm-hmm. And I remember when I was talking to Jeff Blitz about doing the scene, we talked about ways I might fidget a little to sort of show my emotion in this moment. And wardrobe had given me this necklace and I just began to play with it. I love the idea that it's a necklace that Dwight gave her, though. That adds a nice layer. I didn't think that through, though. So,
和格雷格·罗德里格斯。他们说在大约4分30秒时，安吉拉似乎在抚摸一条心形项链，而奥斯卡在谈论德怀特的英雄行为。你认为这条项链是德怀特送给安吉拉的吗？对此有什么想法吗，安吉拉？我从来没想过这个问题。如果我没记错的话，那其实是一个小挂坠。嗯。我记得当我和杰夫·布里茨讨论拍摄这个场景时，我们讨论了我可能会做些什么小动作来表现我那一刻的情绪。服装组给了我这条项链，我就开始玩弄它。不过，我喜欢它是德怀特送给她的项链这个想法。这增加了一个很好的层次。虽然我没想过这一点。所以，
so that's a great idea. Well, we had more questions, Angela, more mail. Please, excuse me, but people want to know. Ellis Friedman said, Angela, you have. You have. You have a have all of these beautiful micro expressions on your face. How are you able to do that without doing too much? You do it a lot in this series, but you really get to shine in this episode. Aw, thank you. That is so nice. I remember when I got the script and I read Oscar's retelling of it, you know, he's just telling it matter-of-factly what happened. But I did a little bit of homework as an actor. I wrote next to Oscar's lines, what emotion that line made me think of. of. And then when I did the scene, I played through those emotions on my face. And they were, you know,
所以那是个好主意。好吧，我们还有更多问题，安吉拉，更多邮件。请原谅，但人们想知道。埃利斯·弗里德曼说，安吉拉，你的脸上有很多美丽的微表情。你是怎么做到不过火的？你在这一系列中经常这样做，但你在这一集中真的大放异彩。哦，谢谢。太好了。我记得当我拿到剧本读到奥斯卡的复述时，你知道，他只是客观地讲述发生了什么。但我作为演员做了一些功课。我在奥斯卡的台词旁边写下了那句台词让我想到的情绪。然后当我拍那个场景时，我就在脸上表现出那些情绪。它们是，你知道，
an example would be like surprise, nervousness, excited, embarrassed. You know what I mean? So I would go through all of that and just kind of very subtly, just do emotions. So as he said his lines, I was thinking of those emotions. I love that. That's so actory, Angela. I know. I did. the actor nerd in me loves it. I love that. Well, Jenna, I can talk about these scenes because they were so juicy for me, but let's move along. I want to talk about Michael's tactics that he has learned on Wikipedia, the best thing ever, and he's going to try him out on Jim, these negotiating tactics. Yes. Yes, he wants to role play. I mean, his ideas are Yelene Bexie. you mumble your words, you change location, surprise them. Guys, I looked up the art of negotiation online, because of course I did. And? This is not how you do it.
比如惊讶、紧张、兴奋、尴尬。你知道我的意思吗？所以我经历了所有这些，只是非常微妙地表现出来。所以当他说他的台词时，我在想那些情绪。我喜欢这个。这太“演员”了，安吉拉。我知道。我做了。我内心的演员书呆子很喜欢它。我喜欢这个。好吧，珍娜，我可以谈谈这些场景，因为它们对我来说太有意思了，但让我们继续吧。我想谈谈迈克尔从维基百科上学到的策略，这是有史以来最好的东西，他要尝试在吉姆身上使用这些谈判策略。是的。是的，他想角色扮演。我的意思是，他的想法是“Yelene Bexie”。你含糊其辞，你改变地点，给他们惊喜。伙计们，我在网上查了谈判的艺术，因为我当然查了。然后呢？这不是你应该做的方式。
As we are learning, Michael's ways are not the way to do it. I will tell you, Jenna, there is so much to learn about negotiation. And the more I read, the more I realized what a horrible negotiator I have been in my career. it's a true art form. There's a whole theory of negotiation. I found it fascinating. But one of the things every sort of guide to negotiating has in common. And I read Forbes magazine, Business Insider. I went to the Harvard Law School website. And one of the things is they all say, do your homework, know your goals, listen, ask for what you want, right? And also, one of the things they talk. They talk about. about is that a negotiation is not the same as conflict. You have to be willing to compromise
正如我们所了解到的，迈克尔的方式不是正确的方式。我告诉你，珍娜，关于谈判有很多要学的。我读得越多，就越意识到我在职业生涯中是一个多么糟糕的谈判者。这是一种真正的艺术形式。有一整套谈判理论。我觉得它很迷人。但每一种谈判指南都有一个共同点。我读了《福布斯》杂志，《商业内幕》。我去了哈佛法学院的网站。其中一点是他们都说，做功课，明确你的目标，倾听，要求你想要的，对吧？而且，他们谈论的一件事是，谈判不等于冲突。你必须愿意妥协
or just say no if you don't like the offer. And I think I grew up, Jenna, I don't know if it was just my family dynamic, but to negotiate something seemed confrontational. And it's not. It's just expressing your needs and seeing if that other person or other company or whatever is willing to meet you halfway and you go back and forth. I found it really, it felt like a mini therapy session for me. Well, I remember I got some amazing advice from a very successful businessman right before I was getting ready to negotiate a big deal. And he said, something that I've noticed, especially about women in negotiation, is they tend to negotiate with themselves first and they go in with where they've already compromised.
或者如果你不喜欢这个提议就说不。我觉得我长大的过程中，珍娜，我不知道是不是因为我的家庭动态，谈判某事似乎是对抗性的。但事实并非如此。这只是表达你的需求，看看对方或另一家公司是否愿意和你折中，然后你们来回商量。我觉得这对我来说就像一次小型治疗。嗯，我记得我在准备谈判一笔大交易之前，从一位非常成功的商人那里得到了一些很棒的建议。他说，我注意到的一件事，特别是在女性谈判中，她们倾向于先和自己谈判，她们带着已经妥协的结果去谈判。
So he's like, if you want three weeks vacation, I see women especially talk themselves out of that or they think that's too much to ask for. So then they ask for two and then they get one. And he said, so my advice to you is go in there and really ask for what you want. Like don't negotiate with yourself first. Just negotiate with the company. Yeah. And I've never forgotten it.
所以他说，如果你想要三周假期，我看到女性特别容易说服自己放弃，或者她们认为要求太多了。所以她们要求两周，然后得到一周。他说，所以我的建议是，直接去要求你想要的。不要先和自己谈判。直接和公司谈判。是的。我永远不会忘记这一点。
And it's not conflict. Negotiating is not conflict. It's totally different. It's going in there to be an advocate for yourself. Yes. I loved it. So anyway, there's tons of really great things online. And then I won't even get into this.
而且这不是冲突。谈判不是冲突。它是完全不同的。它是为了成为你自己的倡导者。是的。我喜欢它。所以无论如何，网上有很多很棒的东西。然后我甚至不会深入讨论这个。
Somehow I ended up on a website that talked about the best and worst negotiations throughout history. That involved countries and policy. and it was fascinating. Well, I need to know about that. I know. For later. For later. This is a big episode.
不知何故，我最终进入了一个网站，讨论了历史上最好和最坏的谈判。涉及国家和政策。这太迷人了。嗯，我需要了解那个。我知道。以后再说。以后再说。这一集很大。
Well, now, Angela, we go back to the annex. And Toby is clearly taking statements on what happened. And he is taking Dwight's statement. In the meantime, Ryan and Kelly are on the other side of the partition and they are eavesdropping. And they start getting in a fight because Ryan is like, I wonder what I would have done if I I'd been there. And Kelly's like, I know exactly what you would have done. Because when that kid dropped their shake on me, when we were on the Ferris wheel,
好吧，现在，安吉拉，我们回到附楼。托比显然在记录发生的事情的陈述。他正在记录德怀特的陈述。与此同时，瑞安和凯利在隔板的另一边，他们在偷听。他们开始吵架，因为瑞安说，我想知道如果我在场我会做什么。凯利说，我完全知道你会做什么。因为当那个孩子把奶昔洒在我身上时，我们在摩天轮上的时候，
you just laughed. And you didn't stand up for me. And oh, this starts a whole thing. Ryan and Kelly remind me of that S&L sketch, the Bickersons. Do you remember that? Yes. The couple that, like, gets really awkwardly fights at the dinner table and then makes out in the hallway at a party.
你只是笑了。你没有为我挺身而出。哦，这引发了一场大戏。瑞安和凯利让我想起了那个SNL的小品，《Bickersons》。你记得吗？是的。那对在餐桌上尴尬地吵架，然后在派对的走廊里亲热的夫妇。
And they're doing all of this behind Toby. And he has a brilliant line where he says, I don't think Michael intended to punish me by putting Ryan back here with Kelly. But if he did intend that, wow, genius. Yeah. Well, now at 7 minutes, 40 seconds, guys, Daryl has arrived to negotiate with Michael. And Michael is already trying out his tactics. He's going to change the location at the last minute. But then he changes it back.
他们就在托比身后做这一切。他有一句精彩的台词，他说，我不认为迈克尔打算通过把瑞安和凯利放在这里来惩罚我。但如果他确实有这个打算，哇，天才。是的。好吧，现在在7分40秒，伙计们，达里尔来和迈克尔谈判了。迈克尔已经在尝试他的策略了。他要在最后一刻改变地点。但后来他又改回来了。
And then they sit in silence. Yes. And then he won't speak first. Oh, that was so awkward. They sat there for so long. I love Craig Robinson in these scenes. He's so still, right? He's just sitting there.
然后他们沉默地坐着。是的。然后他拒绝先开口。哦，那太尴尬了。他们坐了那么久。我喜欢克雷格·罗宾逊在这些场景中的表现。他太安静了，对吧？他只是坐在那里。
And it so confuses Michael. Like, Michael does not understand. So finally, he says, I'm declining to speak first. Yeah, he can't take it anymore. And Daryl's like, all right, I'll start. Well, I think Daryl, if you guys read about negotiations, theory. He has come with a clear vision of what he wants. And there's no BS. He's very upfront. And Michael is doing all this weird stuff and cannot understand that Daryl is not thrown by it. And it's at this
这让迈克尔非常困惑。迈克尔根本不明白。所以最后，他说，我拒绝先开口。是的，他受不了了。达里尔说，好吧，我开始。嗯，我想达里尔，如果你们读过谈判理论。他带着明确的愿景来了，知道他想要什么。没有废话。他非常直率。而迈克尔在做所有这些奇怪的事情，却无法理解达里尔并没有被他搞糊涂。就在这一刻
moment when Daryl says, Michael, are you wearing a woman's suit? I think he says, are you wearing lady clothes? That's right. And Michael's like, what are you talking about? Michael goes on to tell this talking head that I love. He said he found a suit in a bin. And there were a lot of people and they were rifling through things like crazy. And I don't know. Maybe the suit is bisexual. It's made by mysterious. And there's buttons on the wrong side. Maybe that's the mystery. It's European. Okay. It's a European cut. He just is like rambling all this stuff. And Jenna, I love the idea that Michael went to some crazy day after Thanksgiving. Black Friday craziness at some, like, department store and was rifling through a bin. Yeah. And he was really proud of it. I think he really did think he had bought, like, a European suit. On sale. Well, he comes out into the bullpen and he's like, Pam, Pam, will you please tell everyone that this is not a woman's suit? And Pam is like, oh my gosh, it doesn't have any pockets. And then when Steve. turns around and like shows how he can't put his hands in his back pockets. It makes me laugh
达里尔说，迈克尔，你穿的是女装吗？我想他说的是，你穿的是女士衣服吗？没错。迈克尔说，你在说什么？迈克尔接着说了那段我喜欢的独白。他说他在一个箱子里找到了一套西装。当时有很多人，他们像疯了一样翻找东西。我不知道。也许这套西装是双性恋的。它是神秘制造的。而且扣子在错误的一边。也许这就是谜团。它是欧洲的。好吧。这是欧洲剪裁。他只是在胡言乱语。珍娜，我喜欢迈克尔在感恩节后的某个疯狂的黑色星期五去百货公司翻箱子的想法。是的，他真的很自豪。我想他真的以为他买了一套欧洲西装。打折的。好吧，他走到办公室里说，帕姆，帕姆，请告诉大家这不是女装。帕姆说，天哪，它连口袋都没有。然后当史蒂夫转过身，展示他怎么不能把手放进后口袋时，这让我笑得
so hard. Yeah. And Phyllis is like, and it has shoulder pads. Well, let me just say, Angela, this scene points out something that has been a pet peeve of mine for a long time, more than a pet peeve. So if you'll excuse me, I need to get my soapbox and I'm going to be there for a second. I was going to say, are you about to stand up on a soapbox? I am. I want to discuss the lack of adequate pockets on women's clothing. Okay. I know this about you already. Go. Well, first of all, I did a deep dive on pockets because it has bothered me for a long time. You know, Angela, I've had back problems, so it is not comfortable or practical for me to carry a purse. So I had this idea, I'm going to just carry a wallet in my pocket. Men do it all the time. Why can't I do that?
太厉害了。是的。菲利斯说，而且它有垫肩。好吧，让我说，安吉拉，这一幕指出了一个我长期以来的心病，不仅仅是心病。所以请原谅，我需要拿出我的肥皂箱，我要在那儿待一会儿。我正想说，你是不是要站在肥皂箱上？我是。我想讨论女性服装缺乏足够口袋的问题。好的。我已经知道你这一点了。说吧。嗯，首先，我深入研究了口袋，因为它困扰了我很久。你知道，安吉拉，我有背部问题，所以背着钱包对我来说既不舒服也不实用。所以我有个主意，我只要把钱包放在口袋里就行了。男人总是这样做。为什么我不能那样做？
But whenever I would try to put like my phone or a wallet in my pockets, they pop out when I sit down. And here is why, are you ready? I don't know if I'm ready. Bring it. So in the beginning, all clothing was made without pockets. And everyone, men and women carried around a little pouch with their money and belongings. If you've ever watched Little House on the Prairie, you've seen it. Both Ma and Paw, they both carry around a little pocket. Pouch. Yes. All right. And what was it was a pouch called? I don't know. It was just a pocket
但每当我试图把手机或钱包放进口袋时，当我坐下时它们就会弹出来。原因如下，你准备好了吗？我不知道我准备好了没。说吧。所以起初，所有的衣服都没有口袋。每个人，男人和女人都随身带着一个小袋子装钱和财物。如果你看过《草原小屋》，你就见过。妈妈和爸爸，他们都随身带着一个小口袋。袋子。是的。好吧，那个袋子叫什么？我不知道。它只是一个口袋
pouch. Oh, that's so interesting because I know my mom will still sometimes say, will you get me my pocket book? Yes, because your pocket was not a thing that was sewn on you. It was a thing you carried. Oh, that makes very, I always wondered where pocketbook came from. Okay, go on. I'm interested. Let's do it. All right. So about 400 years ago, they started sewing pockets into men's clothing. but not women's clothing. Why not? Well, some historians think that it was a way to keep women sort of powerless. Like you couldn't hide keys or money or do business.
袋子。哦，那太有趣了，因为我知道我妈妈有时还会说，你能帮我拿一下我的“口袋书”吗？是的，因为你的口袋不是缝在衣服上的东西。它是你携带的东西。哦，这很有道理，我一直想知道“口袋书”这个词是怎么来的。好吧，继续。我很感兴趣。让我们继续。好吧。大约400年前，他们开始在男装上缝口袋。但女装没有。为什么不呢？嗯，一些历史学家认为这是一种让女性保持无力感的方式。就像你不能藏钥匙或钱，也不能做生意。
Like your pocket was on the outside of you. You were more vulnerable. Okay. Okay. Less secure. Got it. But then in the late 1800s, there was a movement called the Rational Dress Society. Jenna, are these your people?
就像你的口袋在你的外面。你更脆弱。好的。好的。安全性较低。明白了。但在19世纪末，有一个运动叫“理性着装协会”。珍娜，这些人是你的同类吗？
These are your people, the rational dress society. Well, listen to what these women did. What? Their goal was to quote, dress for comfort and health. Yeah. These are definitely your people. I know. These women are definitely in drawstring pants today.
这些人是你的同类，理性着装协会。好吧，听听这些女性做了什么。什么？她们的目标是引用，“为舒适和健康而着装”。是的。这些人绝对是你的同类。我知道。这些女性今天绝对穿着抽绳裤。
I'll tell you that. Oh, they are. Well, back then, their main goal was to get women to abandon the corset because it was literally unhealthy. healthy to wear a corset. And they also really pushed for women to be able to wear trousers with pockets without stigma. Love it. All right.
我告诉你。哦，她们是。嗯，那时，她们的主要目标是让女性放弃紧身胸衣，因为它确实不健康。穿紧身胸衣。她们还极力推动女性在没有污名的情况下穿带口袋的裤子。喜欢它。好吧。
Eventually in 1920, Coco Chanel started sewing pockets into women's jackets, but it was not until the 1970s when women regularly started wearing jeans that we finally had pockets on a regular basis, Angela. That is crazy to me because, I mean, the 70s are not that long. go, someone sitting right here might have been born in the 70s. I was born in the 70s. I know.
最终在1920年，可可·香奈儿开始在女式夹克上缝口袋，但直到1970年代女性开始经常穿牛仔裤时，我们才真正有了口袋，安吉拉。这对我来说太疯狂了，因为，我的意思是，70年代离现在并不遥远。有人坐在这里可能就是70年代出生的。我是70年代出生的。我知道。
And that's when my ladies started having more pockets. That's crazy. Well, they started having pockets, Angela, but they weren't great. Because pockets on women's clothing are either sewn shut in the example of Michael's suit. What am I supposed to do with that? What am I doing with a faux pocket?
那时我的女士们开始有了更多的口袋。这太疯狂了。嗯，她们开始有了口袋，安吉拉，但它们并不好。因为女装上的口袋要么像迈克尔的西装那样被缝死了。我该拿那个怎么办？我拿一个假口袋做什么？
Yeah. Or they are proportionally smaller than men's pockets. Oh, oh, that's so true. I cannot fit my cell phone in my pants pocket. It falls out of the side. It doesn't fit. Well, Angela, I'll tell you what. I read a report that tested 80 pairs of pockets on both men's and women's blue jeans, all with a waist size of 32. So wait, same size pants. Same size pants. So you can't say, oh, the pockets are smaller because women's pants are smaller than men's pants. No, they are proportionally smaller. On average, women's front pockets were 48% smaller and 6.5% more narrow.
是的。或者它们在比例上比男人的口袋小。哦，哦，那太对了。我的手机放不进裤兜。它会从侧面掉出来。它放不进去。好吧，安吉拉，我告诉你。我读了一份报告，测试了80条男女蓝色牛仔裤的口袋，腰围都是32。等等，同样尺寸的裤子。同样尺寸的裤子。所以你不能说，哦，口袋小是因为女裤比男裤小。不，它们在比例上更小。平均而言，女性的前口袋小了48%，窄了6.5%。
Why? I don't know. I mean, I get it if like it's like a smaller like style. You know what I mean? But on two pairs of jeans that are made the same, you know, Angela, here's my thing. Okay. Am I getting out your soapbox? My soapbox is out.
为什么？我不知道。我的意思是，如果它是一种更小的风格，我明白了。你知道我的意思吗？但在两条制作相同的牛仔裤上，你知道，安吉拉，这是我的观点。好的。我要拿出你的肥皂箱了吗？我的肥皂箱拿出来了。
Okay, get on it. Here's what I want to say, Angela. I think we all know that women do not get paid the same as men, even if they're doing the same job. And we also know now that our pockets don't hold as much. I just think we need bigger pockets and bigger paychecks. Chutching. Can I get my chuching? Equal pay for equal pockets. Hashtag at everyone. Hashtag, Jenna, I liked the history of pockets. I found that fascinating. Yeah, thank you very much. You're welcome.
好的，站上去。我想说的是，安吉拉，我想我们都知道女性的工资没有男人高，即使她们做同样的工作。我们也知道现在我们的口袋装不下那么多东西。我只是觉得我们需要更大的口袋和更大的薪水。叮当。我能得到我的叮当声吗？同工同酬，同等口袋。标签@所有人。标签，珍娜，我喜欢口袋的历史。我觉得那很迷人。是的，非常感谢。不客气。
I'm passionate about pockets, and Angela, I'm also passionate about high-heel shoes and why we shouldn't wear them, but I'll save that for another episode. Okay. Well, you know, Michael is just so embarrassed and devastated. You know, he's not, he thought he was on top of things with this negotiation, and this has really thrown him. Yeah. He said he made one mistake. You can't make any mistakes in negotiating, but he wore one. But he made one mistake wearing women's clothing.
我对口袋充满热情，安吉拉，我也对高跟鞋充满热情，以及为什么我们不应该穿它们，但我会留到下一集再说。好的。嗯，你知道，迈克尔太尴尬和崩溃了。你知道，他不是，他以为他在这次谈判中掌控了一切，但这真的让他很受打击。是的。他说他犯了一个错误。谈判中不能犯任何错误，但他犯了一个。但他犯了一个穿女装的错误。
Yes. And now, Jenna, this scene takes us to the kitchen, and I have labeled this scene at 11 minutes, 15 seconds, Kevin the shit stirer. Yes. I mean, Kevin, listen to what he says to Karen. In front of Stanley and Angela, Kevin says, So Karen, how do you feel that Roy tried to kick your boyfriend's ass over another woman? I mean, Kevin, sit down, Kevin. You need to sit down. But then Angela is like, you know, I wasn't there. I mean, what happened? I wasn't there because she wants Karen to tell her the story. She cannot get enough. I remember talking to Phil Shea about what I should be eating in this scene. And we thought it would be kind of funny if she's eating grapes. It's a very sort of like, like, renaissance moment for her of like the lady eating. grapes being titillated by a story.
是的。现在，珍娜，这一幕把我们带到了厨房，我在11分15秒处标记了这个场景，“凯文，搅屎棍”。是的。我的意思是，凯文，听听他对凯伦说了什么。在斯坦利和安吉拉面前，凯文说，所以凯伦，你觉得罗伊因为另一个女人试图踢你男朋友的屁股，你感觉如何？我的意思是，凯文，坐下，凯文。你需要坐下。但安吉拉说，你知道，我不在场。我的意思是，发生了什么？我不在场，因为她想让凯伦告诉她故事。她怎么听都不够。我记得和菲尔·谢谈过我在这场戏里应该吃什么。我们觉得如果她吃葡萄会很有趣。这是一种非常像文艺复兴时期的时刻，女士吃着葡萄，被故事挑逗。
So now we go back to Michael's office. He and Daryl are still negotiating, and Daryl makes a very compelling argument for why he deserves a raise. Yeah, he said he's picking up Roy's slack. I mean, that is so legitimate. But, Jenna, I have to tell you, there is a fantastic blooper moment. If you go to the bloopers on YouTube, you know, Michael is doing that weird mumble tact that we're talking from my back on a ma'amah.
现在我们回到迈克尔的办公室。他和达里尔还在谈判，达里尔为他为什么应该加薪提出了一个非常有说服力的论点。是的，他说他在承担罗伊的工作。我的意思是，这太合理了。但是，珍娜，我必须告诉你，有一个精彩的NG时刻。如果你去YouTube上看NG片段，你知道，迈克尔正在做我们谈到的那种奇怪的含糊策略。
Yeah. Yeah. And there's some great bloopers of Steve and Craig just cracking up. I loved it. Oh, I love that. Well, I don't know if you noticed in the background over Daryl's shoulder, Pam is not at reception. Do you know why? Oh, that's a good catch because she's in the break room.
是的。是的。史蒂夫和克雷格笑得前仰后合的NG片段很棒。我喜欢它。哦，我喜欢那个。嗯，我不知道你有没有注意到在达里尔肩膀后面的背景里，帕姆不在前台。你知道为什么吗？哦，这是一个很好的发现，因为她在休息室。
Yeah. She's in the break room and she's experiencing major heartbreak in the break room. Lady, I titled this scene, despair in the breakroom. Despair! Well, I thought it was so heartbreaking. I felt it warranted a little musical intro. Sam, could you play Heartbreak in the Break Room by Josh Compton? There's a cold one that blows.
是的。她在休息室，她在休息室里经历着巨大的心碎。女士，我给这一幕命名为“休息室里的绝望”。绝望！嗯，我觉得这太令人心碎了。我觉得它值得一个小的音乐前奏。萨姆，你能播放乔什·康普顿的《休息室里的心碎》吗？有一阵冷风吹过。
Through the hallways in the cubicle road At a lonely old phantom of sorrow that's Grant rolls in There's a sad secretary who's a mourning the loss of a friend It's the oldest of stories, heartbreak in the breakroom again. To white if you're near, to lend her an ear, and a jacket to shoulder the pain. She's not PMSing, it's something more pressing. Heartbreak in the break room again.
穿过走廊，在隔间路上，有一个孤独的悲伤幽灵在游荡。有一个悲伤的秘书在哀悼失去的朋友。这是最古老的故事，休息室里再次心碎。德怀特如果你在附近，借给她一个耳朵，一件夹克来承担痛苦。她不是经前综合症，这是更紧迫的事情。休息室里再次心碎。
Yeah, well, ain't that the truth? Heartbreak again. Now, Jenna, this scene when I watched it, I did think of Dwight and Angela's scenes just in the fact of the staging. Yeah. He doesn't look at you. His back is towards you the whole time.
是的，好吧，那不是事实吗？再次心碎。现在，珍娜，当我观看这一幕时，我确实想到了德怀特和安吉拉的场景，就舞台调度而言。是的。他不看你。他的背一直对着你。
Yes. Yeah. And Pam gets pretty vulnerable. here. She's really trying to connect. She says, I'm really sorry. It's over with Roy. And Jim is doing that thing where he's like, oh, yeah, no, I'm sure it's fine. I mean, come on. You guys will get back together again, I'm sure. Yeah. Oh, he's being so cold. So cold. And he doesn't believe her. That's the thing. I really believe that he doesn't believe her. He's like, we'll see. You guys were good together, you'll probably figure it out. And she's just like, oh. Yeah. Oh, she just feels so bad,
是的。是的。帕姆在这里变得相当脆弱。她真的在试图建立联系。她说，我真的很抱歉。和罗伊结束了。吉姆在做那种事情，他说，哦，是的，不，我相信没事的。我的意思是，拜托。你们肯定会复合的，我肯定。是的。哦，他太冷漠了。太冷漠了。他不相信她。这就是重点。我真的相信他不相信她。他说，走着瞧吧。你们在一起很好，你们可能会解决的。她只是说，哦。是的。哦，她只是觉得太糟糕了，
so embarrassed. And you know, Jim has just been down this road too many times with her. I think he's really, really trying to move on. And that's why he's behaving this way in the scene. He's like, I can't do this again. Yeah, well, I think he's probably frustrated with himself that he let himself get to a place emotionally, where he could see them together again. And in Phyllis's wedding, that was just crushed. Yeah. And he's just not going to put himself out there like that anymore. It's too much drama.
太尴尬了。你知道，吉姆和她之间已经经历过太多次这样的事了。我觉得他真的、真的很想向前看。这就是为什么他在这一幕里表现得那样。他就像是，我不能再重蹈覆辙了。是啊，我觉得他可能对自己感到沮丧，因为他让自己在情感上陷入了那种地步，让他觉得他们还能在一起。而在菲利斯的婚礼上，那种希望彻底破灭了。没错。他再也不会那样去冒险了。那太戏剧化了。
So much drama. You know, I get it. I get why he's like, you know what? I'm not going there. Yeah. Well, then in the next scene, we find out that Michael hasn't had a raise in 14 years. He's never been given a raise ever. Ever. And he shows Daryl his pay stub. And Daryl was like, oh, my God, any wonder they're not going to give me a raise. Look at what they're paying you. You've got to ask for a raise. Yeah. And he convinces Michael to call Jan and ask for a raise. But before Michael hits up Jan, we find Jim and Karen in the kitchen.
太戏剧化了。你知道，我明白。我明白他为什么会说，你知道吗？我才不掺和呢。是啊。好吧，接下来的一幕，我们发现迈克尔已经14年没涨过工资了。他从来没涨过工资。一次都没有。他给达里尔看了他的工资单。达里尔当时就想，天哪，难怪他们不给我涨工资。看看他们给你开的工资。你得去要求涨工资。是啊。他劝说迈克尔给简打电话要求涨工资。但在迈克尔找简之前，我们在厨房里看到了吉姆和凯伦。
Yep. Jim is eating his carrots. 15 minutes, 22 seconds. Bag of carrots. Bag of carrots. And, you know, he wants Karen's advice about how he can thank Dwight. And she was like, well, are you feeling guilty for all those pranks she pulled on him? Jim's like, yeah, maybe that's it. And she says, okay, we'll go sell some paper so we can go on a trip. Yeah, focus on work. She's so practical. I know.
没错。吉姆在吃他的胡萝卜。15分22秒。一袋胡萝卜。一袋胡萝卜。而且，你知道，他想听听凯伦的建议，关于他该如何感谢德怀特。她说，你是对你对他做的那些恶作剧感到内疚吗？吉姆说，是啊，也许是吧。她说，好吧，那我们去多卖点纸，这样我们就能去旅行了。是啊，专注于工作。她真是太务实了。我知道。
He's like, dang it, I don't want practicality. I want to play pranks with Pam, but I can't because she keeps breaking my heart. Yes. Well, finally, Michael does pick up the phone. right? He's like, I'm going to call Jan and I'm going to ask for a raise. And he's got Jan on speaker phone. And Darrell is supervising. He's kind of like going to be his support, right? His coach. Yeah. And Jan tells Michael the only way they can discuss a possible raise is if he comes in person by 5 o'clock and he has to bring Toby. And he says, Toby is the worst human being I've ever known.
他心想，该死，我不要务实。我想和帕姆一起恶作剧，但我不能，因为她总是伤我的心。是的。好吧，最后，迈克尔确实拿起了电话，对吧？他说，我要给简打电话，我要要求涨工资。他开了免提。达里尔在监督。他就像是他的后盾，对吧？他的教练。是啊。简告诉迈克尔，他们讨论涨工资的唯一方式就是他必须在5点前亲自过来，而且他必须带上托比。他说，托比是我认识的最糟糕的人。
Michael says, I'm bringing Darrell. And she says, I'm bringing Darrell. And she says, like Michael, we need someone from HR. So now the three of them are going to be on this weird road trip. In the meantime, Angela still wants to hear this story, guys. She's not done. And she asked Creed, here's Creed's version. Ready? Yes. Big fella comes in about 1130 at night, screaming. Jim stole his car. Big fella pulls out a sock full of nickels, shrewd grabs hairspray and a lighter. So insane. So insane. Angel's like, you're useless. Then she goes, to Kelly. And Kelly's like, you know, I think Toby wrote a whole report about it. And Angela's like, ding, ding, ding, ding. And she goes and steals the report. Yes. I mean,
迈克尔说，我要带上达里尔。她说，我要带上达里尔。她说，迈克尔，我们需要人力资源部的人。所以现在他们三个人要进行一场奇怪的公路旅行。与此同时，安吉拉还想听这个故事，伙计们。她还没完呢。她问了克里德，这是克里德的版本。准备好了吗？是的。大个子在晚上11点半左右进来，尖叫着。吉姆偷了他的车。大个子掏出一只装满镍币的袜子，精明地抓起发胶和打火机。太疯狂了。太疯狂了。安吉拉说，你真没用。然后她去找了凯利。凯利说，你知道，我觉得托比写了一份关于这件事的完整报告。安吉拉说，叮，叮，叮，叮。然后她去偷了那份报告。是的。我的意思是，
what is she up to? And I have to point out, we haven't talked about it. This is a very classic Angela Martin hairdo. Yes, I was going to ask you. It looks like the Angela Martin braid, but also it's a ponytail. I think it's the headband braid. Ponytail. I think it's the headband braid. ponytail version. I will tell you it's all my hair. That is not a hair piece. Kim Ferry, the master of hair, she was able to separate a little piece, do this braid over, pin it into a ponytail. And that's all my hair, guys. I love it. Did it give you a headache? It didn't. Those did not give me a headache. It was more like the severe buns. Yeah. Yeah. Well, listen, we're about to hit the road with Michael and Daryl and Toby.
她在搞什么鬼？我必须指出，我们还没谈过这个。这是非常经典的安吉拉·马丁发型。是的，我正想问你。看起来像是安吉拉·马丁的辫子，但又是个马尾辫。我觉得是发带辫。马尾辫。我觉得是发带辫。马尾辫版本。我告诉你，那全是我自己的头发。那不是假发片。金·费里，发型大师，她能分出一小撮头发，编成辫子，然后别进马尾辫里。那全是我自己的头发，伙计们。我喜欢它。它让你头疼吗？没有。那些没让我头疼。更像是那种紧绷的发髻。是啊。是啊。好吧，听着，我们要和迈克尔、达里尔和托比一起上路了。
But before we do, let's take a break and we'll be right back. With Amex Platinum, access to exclusive Amex pre-sale tickets can score you a spot track side. So being a fan for life turns into the trip of a lifetime. That's the powerful backing of Amex. Presale tickets for future events subject to availability and varied by race. Terms and conditions apply. Learn more at mx.ca.
但在我们出发之前，先休息一下，马上回来。有了美国运通白金卡，获得独家美国运通预售门票，让你在赛道旁占有一席之地。所以，成为终身粉丝就能变成一生难忘的旅行。这就是美国运通强大的后盾。未来活动的预售门票视供应情况而定，并因比赛而异。条款和条件适用。了解更多信息，请访问 mx.ca。
slash yanex. This episode is brought to you by Defender. With its 626 horsepower twin turbo V8 engine, the Defender Octa is taking on the Dakar rally. The ultimate off-road challenge. Learn more at land rover.ca. Oh, this is it, the day you finally ask for that big promotion. You're in front of your mirror with your Starbucks coffee.
斜杠 yanex。本集由卫士赞助。凭借其626马力的双涡轮增压V8发动机，卫士Octa正在挑战达喀尔拉力赛。终极越野挑战。了解更多信息，请访问 land rover.ca。哦，就是今天，你终于要要求那次大升职了。你站在镜子前，拿着你的星巴克咖啡。
Be confident, assertive, remember eye contact, but also remember to blink. Smile, but not too much, that's weird. What if you aren't any good at your job? What if they dim out you instead? Okay, don't be silly, you're smart, you're driven, you're going to be late if you keep talking to the mirror. This promotion is yours. Go get them. Starbucks, it's never just coffee.
要自信，坚定，记住眼神交流，但也别忘了眨眼。微笑，但不要笑得太多，那样很奇怪。如果你工作做得不好怎么办？如果他们反而解雇你怎么办？好吧，别傻了，你很聪明，很有干劲，如果你一直对着镜子说话，你会迟到的。这次升职是你的。去争取吧。星巴克，从来不仅仅是咖啡。
Oh, hi, buddy. Who's the best? You are. I wish I could spend all day with you instead. Uh, Dave, you're huff mute. Hey, happens to the best of us. Enjoy some goldfish cheddar crackers. Goldfish have short memories.
哦，嗨，伙计。谁是最棒的？是你。我真希望我能整天和你待在一起。呃，戴夫，你静音了。嘿，这种事谁都会遇到。享受一些金鱼切达饼干吧。金鱼的记忆力很短。
Be like goldfish. All right, so now Toby and Daryl and Michael are in the car. This is a hilarious pairing. No one's comfortable. He's like, you're comfortable? No, you comfortable, no. And then Daryl's like saying maybe I'll crash in New York for the night. And Toby's like, how will we get back?
像金鱼一样。好吧，现在托比、达里尔和迈克尔在车里。这是一个滑稽的组合。没人感到舒服。他说，你舒服吗？不，你舒服吗，不。然后达里尔说，也许我今晚在纽约凑合一晚。托比说，我们怎么回去？
He's like, you could stay. And then, but Michael's not invited. I know. I love this odd grouping of people. This is one of my favorite things. This feels very Mike sure to me as well. He loved to team up odd characters. Angela, I have to say, they bring up the movie Rush Hour in the car, right?
他说，你可以留下。然后，但迈克尔没被邀请。我知道。我喜欢这种奇怪的人员组合。这是我最喜欢的事情之一。这对我来说感觉非常像迈克·舒尔。他喜欢把奇怪的角色凑在一起。安吉拉，我必须说，他们在车里提到了电影《尖峰时刻》，对吧？
And this made me think of the movie Speed. Stay with me here. Do you remember a few podcasts back? You were like line for line quoting Speed? And I was like, when is the last time you watched Speed? And you were like three days ago. Pop quiz, asshole. There it is.
这让我想到了电影《生死时速》。听我说。你还记得几期播客前吗？你像背台词一样引用《生死时速》？我说，你上次看《生死时速》是什么时候？你说三天前。突击测验，混蛋。就是那个。
Well, I got that in my head. And I was like, huh, maybe I should watch Speed. Did you watch Speed? Angela, it is so good. Everybody watch Speed. Okay, Keanu Reeves, Sandra Bullock, Jeff Daniels. I mean, you guys, this movie has everything. It's action, romance, friendship, I mean, and it's peak Keanu Reeves hotness.
好吧，我脑子里一直想着那个。我就想，嗯，也许我应该看看《生死时速》。你看了吗？安吉拉，它太棒了。大家都去看《生死时速》。好吧，基努·里维斯，桑德拉·布洛克，杰夫·丹尼尔斯。我的意思是，伙计们，这部电影什么都有。动作、浪漫、友谊，我的意思是，而且这是基努·里维斯颜值的巅峰。
It is peak Keanu Reeves hotness. Well, Angela, I'll tell you what. I enjoyed Speed so much that then I watched Point Break. Oh, oh, wait, surfs up, bra. Yes. Johnny Utah. Are you kidding me? Let me tell you this.
这是基努·里维斯颜值的巅峰。好吧，安吉拉，我告诉你，我非常喜欢《生死时速》，所以我又看了《惊爆点》。哦，哦，等等，冲浪去吧，兄弟。是的。强尼·犹他。你在开玩笑吗？让我告诉你这个。
You thought that speed was peak Keanu Reeves hotness, but in point break, he starts in the rain and he ends in the rain, okay? It's a beautiful, Catherine Bigelow directed it. Again, there is in the movie Point Break, there is a. five minute, at least five minute foot chase through people's backyards and houses and jumping over fences. When do you see that anymore in movies? I absolutely love both these movies. So I have decided that to get me through the rest of 2020, I will become a Kano Reeves film aficionado, and I think I'm going to start next on the John Wick movies, which I've never seen. Well, Josh has seen the John Wick movies. He told me they might be too violent for me,
你以为《生死时速》是基努·里维斯的颜值巅峰，但在《惊爆点》里，他从雨中开始，在雨中结束，好吗？这很美，凯瑟琳·毕格罗导演的。再说一次，在电影《惊爆点》里，有一场五分钟，至少五分钟的徒步追逐，穿过人们的后院和房子，跳过栅栏。你现在在电影里还能看到这种场景吗？我绝对喜欢这两部电影。所以我决定，为了度过2020年的余下时间，我将成为一名基努·里维斯电影爱好者，我想我接下来要从《疾速追杀》系列开始，我还没看过。好吧，乔什看过《疾速追杀》。他告诉我它们对我来说可能太暴力了，
but I love Keanu Reeves. You know, I love him. Yeah. And I have seen pretty much all of his movies, but maybe I'll watch John Wick with you. Let's watch John Wick, and we'll get back to each other. We're going to have to go into some Bill and Ted's. You know, the new one just came out. And And my friend Aaron Hayes got to kiss Keanu Reeves. Well, you're going to need to get some information on that and bring that to the podcast. Aaron was in Hot Wives of Vegas with me on Hulu. When did she kiss Keanu Reeves? And Bill and Ted's second one.
但我喜欢基努·里维斯。你知道，我喜欢他。是啊。我几乎看过他所有的电影，但也许我会和你一起看《疾速追杀》。我们一起看《疾速追杀》，然后互相交流。我们还得看一些《比尔和泰德》。你知道，新的一部刚出来。而且我的朋友亚伦·海耶斯还亲了基努·里维斯。好吧，你需要了解一些相关信息，并带到播客上来。亚伦和我一起出演了Hulu的《拉斯维加斯辣妈》。她是什么时候亲基努·里维斯的？在《比尔和泰德》第二部里。
Oh. What about a walk in the clouds? What about that one? Yeah, I don't know. I mean, we have a lot to do. Don't get me started on The Matrix, one of my favorite movies ever. Well, I don't need to rewatch those because I've seen them so many times, but I will, because I want to.
哦。那《云中漫步》呢？那部怎么样？是啊，我不知道。我的意思是，我们有很多事要做。别让我开始谈论《黑客帝国》，我最喜欢的电影之一。好吧，我不需要重看那些，因为我已经看过很多次了，但我会看的，因为我想看。
There is no spoon. Yeah. Oh, I'm so excited. I had no idea you went down that. It's what I'm doing now. Oh my God, they play football on the beach. Are you kidding me? All right.
勺子是不存在的。是啊。哦，我太兴奋了。我不知道你竟然深入研究了这个。这就是我现在在做的。哦，天哪，他们在海滩上踢足球。你在开玩笑吗？好吧。
So the guys eventually they get to New York. They get to Dunder Mifflin. And we find Michael sitting in the lobby. And he looks over to the woman sitting next to him. And she is wearing the same suit. You know, Jenna, I looked up how many times does Michael Scott wear women's clothing by accident? This is going to be a recurring thing. It is?
所以他们最终到了纽约。他们到了邓德·米夫林。我们发现迈克尔坐在大厅里。他看向坐在他旁边的女人。她穿着同样的西装。你知道，珍娜，我查了一下迈克尔·斯科特不小心穿女装有多少次？这会成为一件反复出现的事情。是吗？
Yes. Do I not remember this? Okay. In launch party, he has on a shirt that's way too tight. And the consensus is that it was probably a woman's shirt. Okay. And then in nepotism, Aaron mentions that the pants Michael had that she had to return to Talbots or something. So clearly he's bought.
是的。我不记得了吗？好吧。在《发布会》里，他穿了一件太紧的衬衫。大家的共识是那可能是一件女式衬衫。好吧。然后在《裙带关系》里，艾琳提到迈克尔的裤子，她不得不退回塔博茨百货之类的。所以很明显他买过。
some women's suits repeatedly. And he says he won't make that mistake again. Well, we got some mail. We had some questions from Maruna T. Brianna K., Megan S., Rachel Hayes, and Dan Salomon. They said, was Steve really wearing a woman's suit, or was it custom made for him? So, Ange, I reached out to Carrie Bennett, our wardrobe designer. Awesome. Here is what she told me. She said it really was a lady's suit. She did not have time to sew something from scratch because they would have had to also sew a matching suit for the woman in the lobby. So here's what she did. She said, the first thing she did was try to find a woman's suit that would fit Steve and then hope that she could buy an identical one to fit the woman.
好几次女式西装。他说他不会再犯那个错误了。好吧，我们收到了一些邮件。我们有一些来自玛鲁娜·T、布里安娜·K、梅根·S、瑞秋·海耶斯和丹·萨洛蒙的问题。他们问，史蒂夫是真的穿了女式西装，还是为他定制的？所以，安吉，我联系了我们的服装设计师凯莉·贝内特。太棒了。这是她告诉我的。她说那确实是一件女式西装。她没有时间从头缝制一件，因为他们还得为大厅里的那个女人缝制一套配套的西装。所以她是这样做的：她说，她做的第一件事就是试着找一套适合史蒂夫的女式西装，然后希望她能买到一套一模一样的给那个女人穿。
So she went to stores with a measuring tape looking for a jacket and pants that would fit Steve's measurements, but also she said it had to look masculine enough that it would be plausible that Michael would be confused enough to buy it from a bargain bin. Right. She said that Steve was always so wonderful and generous with his time in the fittings and that oftentimes he would learn about a plot point for a future episode from her. And this was one of those times. She said he walked into a fitting. And she was like, so today I'm going to need you to try on all of these women's suits. And Steve was like, for why? And she was like, well, let me tell you, there's going to be an episode next week where this happens.
所以她带着卷尺去商店，寻找既符合史蒂夫尺寸的夹克和裤子，但她也说，它必须看起来足够男性化，这样迈克尔因为困惑而从特价区买下它才显得合理。对吧。她说史蒂夫在试装时总是非常棒，非常慷慨地贡献他的时间，而且他经常从她那里了解到未来剧集的情节点。这就是其中一次。她说他走进试衣间。她说，所以今天我需要你试穿所有这些女式西装。史蒂夫说，为什么？她说，好吧，让我告诉你，下周会有一集发生这种事。
Because, you know, they would give the crew these scripts a couple of weeks in advance so they could prepare. But the actors, we would only get them, what, five days before we started. shooting. Sometimes the day of, Jenna. Sometimes we would get them like an hour before the lunch table read. It depended on what kind of turnaround and how long the script was taking. And I learned about storylines many times in wardrobe. I totally relate to that. I remember learning about Dwight and Angela's wedding because I was going to need to be fitted for a wedding dress. Yeah. Jenna, do you realize that this is the first time we meet Hunter?
因为，你知道，他们会提前几周把剧本给剧组，这样他们就能准备。但演员们，我们通常只有在开拍前五天才能拿到。有时是当天，珍娜。有时我们在午餐剧本朗读前一小时才拿到。这取决于周转时间以及剧本需要多长时间。我在服装间多次了解到故事情节。我完全能感同身受。我记得了解到德怀特和安吉拉的婚礼，因为我需要去试穿婚纱。是啊。珍娜，你意识到这是我们第一次见到亨特吗？
Yes, played by Nicholas Degosto. And Michael's like, you didn't tell me you hired James Vanderbeak. Well, you know, Angela, this guy has a very extensive resume. I looked him up, but he was in the movie Election with Reese Witherspoon and Matthew Broderick. I love that movie. Yes. He has starred in Gotham and trial and error. But I was very excited because he is the lead of Final Destination,
是的，由尼古拉斯·德戈斯托饰演。迈克尔说，你没告诉我你雇了詹姆斯·范德比克。好吧，你知道，安吉拉，这家伙的简历非常丰富。我查过他，但他出演了瑞茜·威瑟斯彭和马修·布罗德里克主演的电影《选举》。我喜欢那部电影。是的。他主演了《哥谭》和《试错》。但我非常兴奋，因为他是《死神来了》的主角，
and I'm a huge fan of the Final Destination movies. I've never seen one of them. What? Well, you hadn't seen speed. Come on. I've seen speed. I just hadn't seen speed in a while. Had you seen Point Break?
我是《死神来了》系列的超级粉丝。我一部都没看过。什么？好吧，你没看过《生死时速》。得了吧。我看过《生死时速》。我只是有一段时间没看了。你看过《惊爆点》吗？
Of course I've seen Point Break. It came out in 1991 when I was a senior in high school. Of course I saw it. Every girl who was 17 years old saw Point Break. Okay. I haven't seen Final Destination. Is it a scary movie? Do they have to get somewhere and if they don't get there, they die or something?
我当然看过《惊爆点》。它1991年上映时我还是高中生。我当然看过。每个17岁的女孩都看过《惊爆点》。好吧。我没看过《死神来了》。那是恐怖片吗？他们必须到达某个地方，如果没到，他们就会死之类的？
It's their final destination. Here's what happens. Everyone starts the same but different. There's a major catastrophe. For example, in Final Destination 5, they are supposed to take a bus over a bridge. Who's they? Like a group of kids. It's always like a group of teenagers are traveling somewhere by plane or.
那是他们的“终点站”。事情是这样的。每个人开始时都一样，但又不同。会发生一场重大灾难。例如，在《死神来了5》中，他们应该乘公共汽车过桥。谁是他们？就像一群孩子。总是像一群青少年去某个地方旅行，坐飞机或者。
bus or maybe on the highway, and like a major accident happens and they're all killed. Asteroid, something like that? No, it's not science fiction, Angela. Oh, okay. There's no asteroid that pulls from the sky. Okay. Okay. It's always like a series of little things that lead to a giant calamity.
公共汽车，或者可能在高速公路上，然后发生了一场重大事故，他们都死了。小行星，之类的？不，这不是科幻小说，安吉拉。哦，好吧。没有从天而降的小行星。好吧。好吧。总是像一系列小事情导致了一场巨大的灾难。
So like someone's tire bursts and then the car spins and then that hits a truck and then things fall off the truck and hit another truck and then something slams into something. and then the whole bridge ends up collapsing, right? And they're trapped on the bus hanging from the bridge or something? No, they're dead. They all die. Oh, oh. Then how do you have a movie?
比如某人的轮胎爆了，然后车打滑，然后撞上了一辆卡车，然后东西从卡车上掉下来撞上了另一辆卡车，然后什么东西撞上了什么东西。然后整座桥最终倒塌了，对吧？他们被困在挂在桥上的公共汽车里之类的？不，他们死了。他们都死了。哦，哦。那怎么拍电影？
Exactly. Every movie opens up with like a giant disaster moment. And then it rewinds and you realize that it's a person's premonition of what's about to happen. And that person freaks out and says, everybody get off the bus. We're all going to die. We're all going to die. And he convinces everyone to get off the bus and they think he's crazy. and they get off the bus
正是如此。每部电影都以一个巨大的灾难时刻开场。然后倒带，你意识到这是一个人的预感，关于即将发生的事情。那个人吓坏了，说，大家都下车。我们都要死了。我们都要死了。他劝说每个人下车，他们以为他疯了。他们下了车，
and then everything happens as they envisioned it. But they live because of the person's weird premonition, right? Okay. But here's the problem, Angela. Do they all die anyway? They were meant to die on that bus
然后一切都如他所预见的那样发生了。但他们活了下来，因为那个人的奇怪预感，对吧？好吧。但问题是，安吉拉。他们最终还是都死了吗？他们注定要死在那辆公共汽车上，
and they've cheated death and so death is now going to come for them slowly one by one in the order that they would have died in the accident. Ah, okay. Yeah. It's the same plot every time.
他们欺骗了死神，所以死神现在要慢慢地一个接一个地来找他们，按照他们在事故中本该死去的顺序。啊，好吧。是啊。每次情节都一样。
But they're great. it sounds really stressful it it's i like movies i i like it they relax me and um i shouldn't say they're relaxing no i think they do jena i think they do because i think i love you but you will play out the worst case scenario of every situation yeah to sort of prepare yourself yeah so i think movies like this are all horrible worst case scenarios and in your mind you're like, oh, yeah, I would think about that. I can relate to that. Yes, Angela, thank you for saying this. I found uncut gems very, I don't want to say soothing, but I just want to say that my brain operates on that level of stress and anxiety all the time. So when I see it depicted, it's sort of,
但它们很棒。听起来压力很大。我喜欢电影，我喜欢它，它们让我放松，嗯，我不应该说它们让人放松。不，我觉得它们确实让人放松，珍娜，我觉得它们确实，因为我觉得我爱你，但你会把每种情况的最坏情况都演练一遍，是啊，为了让自己做好准备，是啊，所以我认为像这样的电影都是可怕的最坏情况，在你的脑海里你会想，哦，是的，我会想到那个。我能感同身受。是的，安吉拉，谢谢你这么说。我觉得《原钻》非常，我不想说让人舒缓，但我只想说我的大脑一直处于那种压力和焦虑水平。所以当我看到它被描绘出来时，它有点，
it's like it cancels it out. And I feel like, oh, finally, someone's meeting me where I am. Yeah. You feel seen. I think you feel seen. Yeah. So whereas I know like you or Lee watch a movie like that and you're like, I can't handle this. I can't do this. Right. Yeah. That's not that's not recreation for me. I don't want to feel like that in my free time. I want to watch Pride and Prejudice. I want to watch Kira Knightley say Mr. Dassey. Mr. Darcy. Yeah. Yeah. Well, anyway, that was a little bit of a tangent, but I just want you to know that. That's Hunter. So now Roy is coming to collect his final paycheck. You know Angela must be very excited. She's so thrilled now. Roy and Dwight are in the same room.
就像它抵消了它。我觉得，哦，终于有人理解我了。是啊。你感到被看见了。我觉得你感到被看见了。是啊。所以虽然我知道像你或李看那样的电影，你会说，我受不了这个。我做不到。对吧。是啊。那对我来说不是娱乐。我不想在空闲时间有那种感觉。我想看《傲慢与偏见》。我想看凯拉·奈特莉说达西先生。达西先生。是啊。是啊。好吧，无论如何，那有点跑题了，但我只是想让你知道。那是亨特。所以现在罗伊要来领他最后的工资了。你知道安吉拉一定很兴奋。她现在太激动了。罗伊和德怀特在同一个房间里。
Oh, anything could happen. Yeah. And there's a moment where Kevin runs out and he goes, Jim, Roy, look out. Like, so delayed. It's too late. He's pointing a Twizzler? Is that what it is? It's a Twizzler or a Red Vine.
哦，什么都可能发生。是啊。有一刻凯文跑出来说，吉姆，罗伊，小心。就像，延迟太久了。太晚了。他指着一根甘草糖？是那个吗？那是甘草糖还是红藤条。
We had a big, big container of them, remember, in the kitchen? Oh, yeah, they were red vines. I remember I got into a big debate on set about the red vines? Yes, because I like red vines. And then there's the Twizzler camp. And the two don't see eye to eye. You know what? I can enjoy both a twizzler and a red vine,
我们有一个很大很大的容器装它们，记得吗，在厨房里？哦，是的，那是红藤条。我记得我在片场关于红藤条进行了一场大辩论？是的，因为我喜欢红藤条。然后还有甘草糖阵营。两者意见不合。你知道吗？我可以同时享受甘草糖和红藤条，
but if I had to choose, I might go red vine. I'm a red vine. Yeah. Yeah. So there's now sort of this awkward apology moment where Roy apologizes to Jim. And Jim's like, yeah, no worries. And then Dwight is ready, you know, in case he's, Roy's going to lunge again. But he's not.
但如果我必须选择，我可能会选红藤条。我是红藤条派。是啊。是啊。所以现在有一种尴尬的道歉时刻，罗伊向吉姆道歉。吉姆说，是啊，没关系。然后德怀特准备好了，你知道，以防罗伊再次猛扑。但他没有。
He's just embarrassed and he feels bad. And he asks Pam if she'll have coffee with him one last time. Yeah, he says he just has a few things he has to get off his chest. And she agrees. So then we go to this coffee place. And do you remember this place, Angela, we see a shot of it and it says the hungry fox. It's a real place. and it's still there.
他只是感到尴尬，他感觉很糟糕。他问帕姆是否愿意最后一次和他喝咖啡。是啊，他说他只是有几件事要倾诉。她同意了。所以我们去了这家咖啡店。你还记得这个地方吗，安吉拉，我们看到了它的镜头，上面写着“饥饿的狐狸”。这是一个真实的地方，而且它还在那里。
Yes. And I would go there. They actually, they're sort of one of these places, guys, where you can get a little bit of everything. It's kind of like a diner. And I've had their cheeseburger. It's so good.
是的。我会去那里的。他们实际上，他们是那种地方，伙计们，你可以买到各种各样的东西。它有点像小餐馆。我吃过他们的芝士汉堡。太好吃了。
I used to eat there all the time too because it was very close to our offices. And Greg told me that he often in the mornings, before he went into work, he would stop there and have breakfast and kind of set his head for the day, basically. And so it's kind of, kind of cool that we got to shoot at this place that we all really would eat at. Yeah, I loved it.
我也经常在那里吃，因为它离我们的办公室很近。格雷格告诉我，他经常在早上上班前，会在那里停下来吃早餐，基本上为这一天定下基调。所以，能在我们大家都真的会去吃的地方拍摄，感觉很酷。是啊，我喜欢它。
It's a little mom and pop place. Well, I have a question for you, Jenna. When I was watching the scene, it occurred to me, I mean, would Pam have wanted the camera crew to come to this? It's such an intimate moment. It's a farewell. And I was so surprised that she would agree to let the camera crew come along. It's interesting that you asked that question because I actually had the same thought. I thought that it was interesting that this was done on camera. But I had another thought, which was maybe Pam doesn't want to be alone with Roy. Well, that's true. The camera crew would have been a buffer, especially, you know, we learned that Pam had become friends with some of the crew, right?
这是一个小夫妻店。好吧，我有个问题问你，珍娜。当我在看这一幕时，我想到，我的意思是，帕姆会希望摄制组来这里吗？这是一个如此亲密的时刻。这是一个告别。我很惊讶她会同意让摄制组跟来。你问那个问题很有趣，因为我实际上也有同样的想法。我觉得有趣的是，这是在镜头前完成的。但我还有另一个想法，那就是也许帕姆不想和罗伊单独在一起。好吧，那是真的。摄制组会是一个缓冲，特别是，你知道，我们了解到帕姆已经和一些工作人员成为了朋友，对吧？
Yeah, later we'll find that out. Yeah, so maybe it in some way was this bug. for this moment. And she wasn't sure how that moment was going to play out. Yeah. So it might have made her feel, I don't know, a little better to have them there. Yeah. Okay.
是啊，后来我们会发现这一点。是啊，所以也许它在某种程度上是这个时刻的屏障。而且她不确定那一刻会如何发展。是啊。所以有他们在场可能会让她感觉，我不知道，好一点。是啊。好吧。
I'll buy that. Well, Roy really apologizes to Pam. And she apologizes as well. She says, we, you know, we both made bad decisions. But then Roy says, so are you going to date Jim now? And he says it's sort of like it would be okay with him. Yeah, I don't know if it would be okay if he's just like curious and wanting to know up front so he knows what he has to hear about, you know, through the grapevine.
我接受这个说法。好吧，罗伊真的向帕姆道歉了。她也道歉了。她说，我们，你知道，我们都做了错误的决定。但随后罗伊说，那你现在要和吉姆约会了吗？他说这听起来好像他会同意。是啊，我不知道如果他只是好奇，想提前知道，这样他就知道他必须听到什么，你知道，通过小道消息。
But Pam says no. She's like he has a girlfriend. But Roy is like, I mean, you called off our wedding for the guy. And now you're not going to date him. I just don't get you, Pam. Well, he calls you Pammy. And you also say, well, there were other reasons, too, which I think is Pam just being polite and not saying, you did this, you didn't do this. She doesn't want to run him, you know, through the wringer and just leaves it at that.
但帕姆说不。她说他有女朋友。但罗伊说，我的意思是，你为了那个家伙取消了我们的婚礼。现在你又不和他约会了。我就是不懂你，帕姆。好吧，他叫你帕米。而且你也说，嗯，还有其他原因，我认为这是帕姆在礼貌，而不是说，你做了这个，你没做那个。她不想让他经历折磨，就到此为止了。
But I do think that Roy saying that is planting the seed for what Pam's going to do later. Because it's true. It's true. She did call off her wedding to Roy, in part, because she had feelings for Jim. If she did not have feelings for Jim, I'm not sure she would have called off the wedding just because they were not a perfect match. I agree. I think her feelings for Jim and the way Jim sort of held up a mirror to her life changed her.
但我确实认为罗伊说的话是在为帕姆以后要做的事情埋下种子。因为这是真的。这是真的。她确实取消了和罗伊的婚礼，部分原因是她对吉姆有感觉。如果她对吉姆没有感觉，我不确定她是否会仅仅因为他们不是完美的一对就取消婚礼。我同意。我认为她对吉姆的感觉以及吉姆某种程度上像镜子一样照出她的生活改变了她。
And he is the reason. He's a big, big part of the reason. Yeah. All right. Well, that was, we talked about this with David a little bit. That was a really special scene for me. I love doing that scene with him. I just loved doing scenes with David.
他是原因。他是原因中很大很大的一部分。是啊。好吧。好吧，那是，我们和戴维谈过这个。那对我来说是一个非常特别的场景。我喜欢和他一起演那个场景。我就是喜欢和戴维演戏。
He was a great actor. He's a great acting partner. And I was really sad knowing that that was, you know, going to be the last scene we would do for a while. I know. You guys had a really special thing. And I loved being able to watch that scene. He was kind of the first.
他是一位伟大的演员。他是一位伟大的表演搭档。我知道那将是我们一段时间内要做的最后一个场景，我真的很伤心。我知道。你们俩有一种非常特别的关系。我很高兴能看到那个场景。他算是第一个。
major regular character who had been with us from the beginning who was leaving the show. Yes. Yes. And that was, we'd been through a lot. You know, he was part of our origin story. He was with us when the show was struggling. And then he was with us when we started getting awards. And it was really weird to say goodbye. Yeah. Well, lady, we should go back to corporate because we've got some unfinished business there. Michael and Jan are in the throes of negotiation. And he says, give me a raise are no more sex. And Toby just starts taking notes. And Michael's like, what's you're writing down, perv ball? And then I'm telling you, Paul Lieberstein is Toby, crushes it in this talking head. It's so good. He talks about what a groundbreaking case this is going to be when it inevitably
从一开始就和我们在一起的主要常驻角色，他要离开剧组了。是的。是的。那是，我们经历了很多。你知道，他是我们起源故事的一部分。当剧集还在挣扎时，他就在我们身边。然后当我们要开始获奖时，他也在我们身边。说再见真的很奇怪。是啊。好吧，女士，我们应该回到公司，因为我们还有一些未竟之事。迈克尔和简正在谈判中。他说，给我涨工资，否则就没性生活了。托比开始做笔记。迈克尔说，你在写什么，变态球？然后我告诉你，保罗·利伯斯坦饰演的托比，在这个谈话头中表现得太棒了。太好了。他谈到了当这不可避免地
goes to trial. It's so good. Well, Michael cannot help. but make this personal. Yes. Well, right out of the gate, he says we're lovers. I mean, right, right away. Finally, Jan says to Michael, listen, I can give you a 12% raise, but you have to ask me for 15%. Okay? So just ask for 15 and we'll settle at 12.
进入审判时，这将是一个开创性的案例。太棒了。好吧，迈克尔忍不住把这变成个人的。是的。好吧，一上来，他就说我们是恋人。我的意思是，马上，马上。最后，简对迈克尔说，听着，我可以给你涨12%的工资，但你必须向我要求15%。好吗？所以只要要求15%，我们就会以12%成交。
He doesn't get it. He doesn't get it. He says, I want a 15% raise. She said, we can offer you 12. And he says, you said 15. And she's like, oh, Michael. Yeah. Well, he does end up getting his raise.
他不明白。他不明白。他说，我要15%的涨薪。她说，我们可以提供12%。他说，你说的是15%。她说，哦，迈克尔。是啊。好吧，他最终确实涨了工资。
He does. And so does Daryl. And Michael explains that negotiating is an art form. And ultimately, it's more about salary. It's really about the perks. Like having sex with jam. And I mean. moving forward, if Michael ever has another job, which we know he will, how's he going to
他确实涨了。达里尔也涨了。迈克尔解释说，谈判是一门艺术。最终，这更多的是关于薪水。这实际上是关于津贴。比如和简发生性关系。我的意思是。展望未来，如果迈克尔再有另一份工作，我们知道他会有的，他将如何
negotiate? I don't know. I don't know. I don't think he really learned anything. I don't know. Well, now it's the end of the day, Dunder Mifflin. All is quiet. People are leaving. Did you catch as Phyllis is leaving? She mentions it's very sort of under, under dialogue as they're leaving. She says that her and Bob are looking at historical homes near the river. No, I did not catch that. What a great nugget. I'm like, what the heck? I cannot get enough of Bob and Phyllis fans.
谈判？我不知道。我不知道。我不认为他真的学到了什么。我不知道。好吧，现在是邓德·米夫林的一天结束了。一切都很安静。人们正在离开。你注意到菲利斯离开时了吗？她提到了，这非常像是在离开时的对话。她说她和鲍勃正在看河边的历史建筑。不，我没注意到。多好的一个细节。我心想，这到底是怎么回事？我真是看不够鲍勃和菲利斯的粉丝。
I know. I would have loved to see more of them. Something we haven't talked about exactly are all the ways that Jim keeps trying to pay Dwight back. So, like, you know, he tries to give him a display case for his bobblehead. And he tries to give him this certificate of bravery from the Scrant Police Department, but it's, you know, something they give to little kids. Well, it has a teddy bear on it. And he just throws it away. And Jim just can't figure out how he can repay Dwight.
我知道。我本来很想看到更多关于他们的内容。我们还没谈过的一件事是吉姆一直试图报答德怀特的所有方式。所以，你知道，他试图给他一个摇头娃娃的展示柜。他试图给他这个斯克兰顿警察局颁发的勇敢证书，但它是，你知道，给小孩子的那种。好吧，上面有一只泰迪熊。他直接把它扔了。吉姆就是想不出他该如何报答德怀特。
And, well, then he finds a way. Yeah, he does. So, yeah, everyone's left. Angela and Dwight think they're alone. Angela tells Dwight She's heard tales of bravery Yeah A gallant hero
而且，好吧，然后他找到了一个方法。是啊，他找到了。所以，是啊，大家都走了。安吉拉和德怀特以为他们单独在一起。安吉拉告诉德怀特她听到了勇敢的故事，是啊，一位英勇的英雄，
And maybe They'll have to read the report Toby's report together later And Dwight just scoops her up And gives her a big old smooch And who walks out of the bathroom Jim He sees it all
也许他们以后得一起读那份报告，托比的报告，然后德怀特抱起她，给了她一个大大的吻，谁从洗手间走出来？吉姆。他看到了这一切，
And he's like, oh my gosh His face is so brilliant. Now, there are two things that this scene made me think of. So, number one, I noticed that when Rain comes over to you, he sits on your desk. Mm-hmm. Was that intentional so you guys would be kind of the same height to start kissing? Always. Always.
他说，哦，天哪。他的表情太精彩了。现在，这个场景让我想到了两件事。所以，第一，我注意到当雷恩走向你时，他坐在你的桌子上。嗯哼。那是故意的吗，这样你们开始接吻时身高就差不多了？总是。总是。
And almost every scene Dwight and Angela have together, he is seated. Look it up, guys. I totally noticed it. He is what, six foot three, I am five one. And here's the other thing that the scene made me think of, which is that Jim has this talking head where he says, I will never say a word, and now we're even. So this means that Pam never told Jim what she knows about Dwight and Angela's relationship. That's right.
而且德怀特和安吉拉在一起的几乎每个场景，他都是坐着的。查查吧，伙计们。我完全注意到了。他有六英尺三英寸，我五英尺一英寸。这是这个场景让我想到的另一件事，那就是吉姆有一个谈话头，他说，我永远不会说一个字，现在我们扯平了。所以这意味着帕姆从未告诉吉姆她所知道的关于德怀特和安吉拉的关系。没错。
Pam completely kept that a secret. Yeah. Pam, I mean, I will say this. Pam does write by Angela over and over. She does. I was like, I guess I had forgotten that Pam never told Jim. Well, I have a little behind-the-scenes story about this scene. We did probably like three, three or four takes just to get the timing right of Jim walking out and reacting. in one take, Rain sort of does this huge, grand gesture where he shoves everything off Oscar's desk, you know? He like takes his hand and sweeps across the desk and everything goes flying and I'm like, and he picks me up and lays me down on the desk. And we thought it was hilarious. And Jeff Lutz was like, it's probably too much. It's probably too big.
帕姆完全保守了这个秘密。是啊。帕姆，我的意思是，我会说这个。帕姆一次又一次地为安吉拉着想。她确实。我心想，我大概忘了帕姆从未告诉过吉姆。好吧，关于这个场景我有一个幕后故事。我们大概拍了三、三或四次，才让吉姆走出来并做出反应的时机恰到好处。在一次拍摄中，雷恩做了一个巨大的、宏大的手势，他把奥斯卡的桌子上的所有东西都推开了，你知道吗？他用手扫过桌面，所有东西都飞了起来，我心想，他抱起我，把我放在桌子上。我们觉得这太搞笑了。杰夫·卢茨说，这可能太过分了。这可能太大了。
But that kind of goes with your whole, like, grape eating. I know. A whole, like, renaissance passion. I know. Ooh, look at my ankle. Ooh. Yeah. I know, but that cracked me up.
但这和你整个，比如，吃葡萄的风格很搭。我知道。一种，比如，文艺复兴式的激情。我知道。哦，看我的脚踝。哦。是啊。我知道，但这让我笑死了。
But, yeah, that is not the take we went with. And then before the show ends, Andy returns, guys. He is back from anger management. He's not going to blow his second chance. Yes. He walks in the office. and immediately gets pepper sprayed by Dwight. Yes.
但是，是啊，那不是我们最终采用的版本。然后在剧集结束前，安迪回来了，伙计们。他从愤怒管理课程回来了。他不会浪费他的第二次机会。是的。他走进办公室，立刻被德怀特喷了胡椒喷雾。是的。
This leads to Toby taking away all of Dwight's weapons underneath his desk. He had a little Sharpie Star thing. What do they call it? Do you throw the Stirling star? Or Sharpie Star. And he had Nunchucks and pepper spray all duct taped under his desk. Yeah. I think maybe Toby's next stop should be Creed's drawer.
这导致托比没收了德怀特桌子下的所有武器。他有一个小夏普星之类的东西。他们叫它什么？你扔斯特林星？还是夏普星。他还有双节棍和胡椒喷雾，都用胶带粘在桌子下面。是啊。我觉得也许托比的下一站应该是克里德的抽屉。
Because remember when Creed was able to whittle the wooden steak, he opened his drawer and he had like a lot of stuff in there. I feel like there's a world where Creed hits a button and his desk flips up and there's stairs that go below the office into an underground bunker. And he has everything you need for any doomsday scenario. Well, Dwight ends this with a talking head saying he's not a hero. a defender of the office. A real hero is hero from heroes, which was an NBC show on at the time. Huge, huge show. Huge, huge show. Remember? What was there a big catchphrase, protect the cheerleader? I don't remember. Yeah, that sounds right. Save the cheerleader, Sam says. Save the cheerleader. Turns out cheerleader didn't need saving. She had superpowers. Before we say goodbye to the negotiation,
因为记得当克里德能够削木桩时，他打开抽屉，里面有很多东西。我觉得有一个世界，克里德按下一个按钮，他的桌子翻转过来，有楼梯通往办公室下面的地下掩体。他拥有你在任何世界末日场景中需要的一切。好吧，德怀特以一个谈话头结束了这一幕，说他不是英雄。办公室的捍卫者。真正的英雄是《英雄》里的英雄，那是当时NBC的一部剧。非常、非常火的剧。非常、非常火的剧。记得吗？有什么大口号吗，保护啦啦队长？我不记得了。是啊，听起来是对的。拯救啦啦队长，萨姆说。拯救啦啦队长。结果啦啦队长不需要拯救。她有超能力。在我们告别谈判之前，
Jenna, there's something really important we missed. We did not talk about. In the negotiation? Yeah. What? We find out Ryan's middle name. Yes. Ryan Bailey Howard. Yeah. We also find out that Kelly wants to name their child, Usher Jennifer Hudson Kapoor. Well, that's it for the negotiation, you guys. Thank you so much for sending in your questions.
珍娜，我们错过了一件非常重要的事情。我们没谈到。在谈判中？是啊。什么？我们发现了瑞安的中间名。是的。瑞安·贝利·霍华德。是啊。我们还发现凯利想给他们的孩子取名叫亚瑟·詹妮弗·哈德森·卡普尔。好吧，谈判就到这里了，伙计们。非常感谢你们寄来问题。
to David Denman. Yes, David. Thank you so much. Guys, we are getting close to wrapping up season three here. We're in the final stretch of episodes and they are all going to get good. Real good. We'll see you next time. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink. This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwolf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is Produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Juerkins, and our audio engineer and associate producer is Molly Nugent.
给戴维·丹曼。是的，戴维。非常感谢。伙计们，我们快要结束第三季了。我们正处于最后几集的冲刺阶段，它们都会变得很好。非常好。下次见。感谢收听《办公室女士》的第二杯。本集最初是与Earwolf合作创作的。Office Ladies是Odyssey的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·尤金斯，我们的音频工程师和副制片人是莫莉·纽金特。
Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Odyssey的执行制片人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。Office Ladies由比尔·舒尔茨混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。谢谢。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。